it is Wednesday April 12th
beautiful spring day
you know it's off the rails
back again
today's episode is sponsored by
expressvpn and stamps.com we love our
sponsors we love them
well
as you guys all I'm sure saw Monday's
episode was quite a roller coaster
we uh played the call with bbtv
and uh the the battle was going to
continue today actually we had like
lawyers queued up to call in
uh
you know
but this morning I have to tell you
people don't believe the title
I don't believe it either
[Music]
so this morning
I got an email from their uh general
counsel this is the woman I was emailing
with my pen pal
the one you sent the minion meme yeah
yeah to them exactly and so um she's
like hey uh far Farzad Farzad
Starz ad sorry
see I already forgot her name I'm over
it
shark zad that's how I remember
she said hey uh charzad wants to get on
the call with you this morning if
possible you know a good faith cult no
recording they said
I said yeah I'm down you know why not
I'd love to to resolve this uh I don't
want to do all this nonsense but you
know I'll do it
you [__] knew I would I'm just
I'll
you know I'm I'm being careful of what I
say today
maybe yeah yeah that music gets under
your skin I gotta thank God for the
button yesterday boy
this thing right here
powerful piece of technology
there's the Manhattan Project
and then there's the button oh yeah
the most important uh human advances in
science
so anyway Nancy oh whatever I said her
name but she's I was gonna say she's
nice she's awesome it's nothing wrong
with saying her name I was gonna say
that General cancel uh
emailed me and then so
we call that 11. Nancy uh I love her
she's so nice she set up the zoom
and she's like the sweet
old mom
Boomer she didn't know how to use zoom
she did not know how to use zoom I love
it she's like how do I invite uh
charzad and I was like Nancy I was like
Nancy this is great
um you know it's not like you work for a
tech company
she left
she like that she did she liked because
she she was like genuinely the nicest
and happiest sounding person which made
me a giggle even more like she must have
been so confused by the minion meme
oh maybe she couldn't get the attachment
open and she doesn't even know
yeah
so so she gets on the call
she's trying to figure out how to get
charzat on the zoom and then once
Charizard was on the zoom she was trying
to figure out how to pass ownership for
a few minutes
we're just like just hang up Nancy it's
okay just hang up
I the reason I like saying your name my
childhood's best friend's mom was name
was Nancy so I guess I have an affinity
for Nancy's sweet ladies love Nancy's in
general
shout out to all the Nancy yeah
but you know it was funny to meet her
because for some reason
I imagined her being more slick when we
were talking back and forth and her uh
saying
Eve crossed
Business and Professional boundaries
and then when I get on the phone she's
like just the nicest uh she almost like
I don't I don't know her age so don't
offend her but almost like a young nice
kind of in the grandma age
but you know it was funny to me whoops
oops sometimes I open the stream because
I want to see chat and then that always
happens so apologies
but so um so she was nice she was super
nice I was like hey it's nice to meet
you Nancy we're pen pals
oh my God she wasn't she wasn't
she wasn't affected by anything I said
she's like yeah we're pen pals like I
should have asked her what she thought
about my minion meme I didn't it just
slipped my mind
so um
to then she leaves and it's me Ela and
charzat on the phone
well first let me say this at the top
okay
please
please please do not go after email
interact with bbtv employees at all
never ever ever do it it's even worse
than being a beta
that's some omega [__] I want to say
it's this this dispute was between me or
us and them and I will say it has been
resolved
so please please guys
if you're doing any of that crap and I
emphasized that on Monday I did
emphasize that
but please please please please please
guys don't do it don't it's not for me
don't do that for me don't do it for you
just don't do it okay this is all we're
just having this is just family
family only this is a family affair
so I got on the call with charzad
and right at the top she said um
uh we are gonna pay you back the full
amount boom done Conversation Over
And I said Okay
um
I said is it one payment or like
installments
she said one payment I said okay
interesting
then I said is it when is it going out
and she said I don't want to say
anything and and and be wrong but as
soon as possible I said okay interesting
interesting
I was at this point quite uh
I don't want to say almost disappointed
don't say that come on I had already you
know oh this is a huge w why are you
disappointed well I I just want to make
the point that
I was like listen listen scharzan if
this is the route you want to go that's
awesome it's going to be a lot less
trouble for all of us this isn't my
first one but at the same time
play the music Zach
I was ready
[Music]
I was
oh I know you were and you were not
kidding and I said charzad I want to
make one thing clear to you
I am going to accept that payment and
we'll consider it resolved but I will
not put any strings or stipulations
attached to it that's my I'm not going
to give quantifiers for my money return
to me
she said that's fine so she said that's
fine
[Applause]
to me I I I'm a bit conflicted at this
moment we had a cordial conversation we
did what are you conflicted on we
celebrated you seem sad because
no no no it's not that it's it's
we we had a we are we I wouldn't say we
argue we we had a lively discussion just
I said look just between us you know
you're wrong right
it would not be just between you though
because now we're talking about it well
I mean like I'm not recording the call
right you are wrong
because this is my show I feel like I
after everything we've been through I ha
I owe it to everybody to tell what
happened
people are saying is this bait no this
is not bait there's one thousand percent
we are not trolling this is this is the
real deal this is one thousand percent
real
[Music]
um
look ultimately
I said to her I I'm not I can't remove
anything
I just can't I can't do the stipulations
and you know I'll just say this without
getting too deep into it she gracefully
[Music]
accepted that and
agreed to
excuse me pay us back the full amount
people are saying I'm tapping so hard
trust me this is the I did not expect
this at all it's the boy who cried wolf
man
well whatever it is what it is I mean
you know what I mean
so um
people are saying Japan trip here we go
let's go that's right that is an
interesting idea because that's a very
interesting idea that's an amazing idea
really interesting idea unbelievably
interesting all right unbelievable let's
see let's investigate this further you
know I'm so interested that's you know
what that's actually a really we should
do something crazy with them Let's Go
Crazy
like go to Japan like make a competing
Media Company no I'm just kidding let's
start at MCN
we should actually that's that's such a
good point because I never expected to
see a penny of that money back
yeah I I yeah in fact I expected to
spend as much just suing them for no
reason so let's go back to Vegas
so we got 620 000 or 620 000 and as long
as we record it it's a it's do a bit
it's all tax write-off there you go
yeah we can go to Vegas we can go big at
Vegas that was fine I'm sorry I'm sorry
Japan I'm sorry Japan here's my problem
with Japan it's just too time consuming
I can't take that much time away from
the family and stuff it's just I can't
do it bring them
bring my kids
it's amazing family vacation you know
see the world he was about to be I mean
Bruce is like a year old okay traveling
with when he was pregnant is well she's
not yet pregnant but Bruce is a year old
Japan is not happening I'm sorry guys
I know
I'm sorry it's just not it's just not in
the car
I'm not ready I'm not ready I'm just not
ready to take that kind of trip right
now because like we'd have to go there
for at least a week right yeah you don't
fly to Japan and not yeah yeah no you'd
want to stay for a while but then what
do we do about the show you saying we do
shows in Japan yeah
easy we do shows in Japan I think we can
do a live show there in Japanese
probably not that part but all but yeah
we could do a live show in Japan can we
do something fun Hassan was just there
he was like live streaming walking the
streets yeah but we don't we're not a
problem yeah but unlike Hassan we
actually put effort into our content
just kidding son you know I mean he went
to the other side of the planet for
content
that seems like a lot of effort no he
took a holiday
but can we do something like more local
you know what I mean
like a crazy weekend in Vegas I can do
Hawaii is a lot closer than Japan Hawaii
yeah I love it's like half of the best
idea it's like I'm bitter I'm bitter
about Hawaii why are you better about
Hawaii
because our last trip was so lame I felt
like oh me and Eli went there Hawaii
uh
trying to think what else is close I
don't know
I love the idea of us just taking a
bougie ass trip on
you know what we'll do Charizard we'll
wear bbtv shirts bbtv hats there you go
you could lay out on our bbtv towels
like the Vlog Squad at Coachella right
right
it's gonna be great in fact Charizard
why don't you join us
I'm not paying for you for the record
you'll have to
pay for yourself Nancy I'll pay for you
you're invited
people are saying Canada I'm gonna avoid
Canada while uh for a little while I'm
gonna lay low in Canada
God dang I
Mexico I'm not trying to die Baltimore
okay I say we go on a barbecue tour of
Texas
got some good barbecue tour
some good barbecue barbecue Tire yeah
barbecue tour Texas yeah
get some yeehaws going on I like you
high there we go
it's affordable uh Japan crew fun thank
you for the five but uh we're not going
to Japan thank you though Jamie
um I do want to say also yesterday
morning they unlinked us
so we are free all the money everything
now is coming to us they're they're out
of the picture this is all us now
pretty pretty crazy
I mean you guys got any other ideas I'm
thinking like a weekend trip I'm sorry I
just it's so hard for me to get away
getting downgraded but I'll go but I'll
we'll go all out dude
we can take like the private uh
how do you call that the jet Suite the
jet Suite ax to Vegas so we can all fly
privately it's like a 40 minute flight
it's awesome
we can take like a black SUV there
together
Sam says go to a ranch what does that
even mean let's go to a ranch Ethan it's
so fun what does that mean she wants to
go like be a canal girl Texas barbecue
Like a Dude Ranch kind of thing Dude
Ranch we go Wrangle some cattle what do
we do at a Dude Ranch hang out with
dudes man
[Music]
everyone says visit love we just show up
at Love's door hey can we stay here
Sweden I mean that's about as that's a
long time travel
what about a million dollar Visa I've
heard you if you have a million dollars
you can get a Visa
well it's not you're 62 percent of the
way we'd have to yeah yeah yeah
oh but I'll fly you out [__] I got crazy
money I'll fly you out I got crazy bbtv
money I'll fly you out you want to come
out can you come on wait can you when
you're on this doing this process
uh just check with the attorney just
check yeah yeah yeah yeah I'll fly you
out ain't no [__] problem there for
me baby bbtv sends the regards what
about uh it is my money what about
Disney World
what about Dave and Buster's Zach what
about oh dude we could shut down Dave
and Buster's boy
what about Alaska if Sam says go to a
ranch you can ride horses go rafting
it's all inclusive with food and
everything I lied I agree with Sam I
think we should j-r-h-n-br I want to
ride a horse let's go to a ranch
okay you have any good rants Ranch ideas
let's go to this it doesn't strike me as
like a bougie vacation let's go to the
Four Seasons there's probably nice ones
go to the forts you're actually
interested in that cam wants this to be
us
oh no
would it be interested specifically but
would it be insensitive if we reenacted
yeah I think there's someone hanging
right there yeah that would be very
insensitive all dressed up like Logan
Paul it would not be very sensitive at
all AV can be the cadaver
like not for real I mean it doesn't have
to be you I didn't mean anything by that
yeah no I'm down
it'll be theater
yeah
Sam has a ranch hard it's very expensive
random says okay as long as it's
expensive
as long as it's a big waste of mine
don't you guys want to do like bougie
ass Vegas trip I'll give everyone a
bunch of money so like
well I mean if you want to just give me
a bunch of money dude Vegas would be the
move I I can't go to Vegas without love
any love I've never he's coming in Vegas
okay
I know you haven't wait how old are you
I'm 23. okay good yeah I was at school
though when you guys went last year
right right I'm open to other ideas but
if we go to Vegas I can give everyone
like a thousand bucks just to gamble
with pay for the private Suite we'll see
a really nice hotel I mean that doesn't
sound bad to me but I want to go back to
that pizza place we ate at oh that was
good that was so good I remember that
yeah but I'm open I'm open to
suggestions
Disney World I don't know I've never
been to Disney World isn't the same
thing no no it's like way bigger yeah
what's different about I thought it's
the same rides they got like Animal
Kingdom Epcot like there's different
even Parks it's like 10 times the size
is it you guys want to go to Disney
World we can do the whole tour there and
stuff
yeah but if we do it like the like the
the bougie fancy thing we did at
Disneyland yeah of course we'll do that
what the hell of course we must do that
Dan I got 620k brother I mean I'm not
yeah
I'm sure everybody'd be down for that
that check better clear now as far as
that or there's gonna be a lot of
disappointment yeah meanwhile bbtv
they're like ah let's not pay him [__]
shut up meanwhile Charizard's like we're
about to go bankrupt and these guys are
talking about no I'm just kidding she
she assured me their finances are
fantastic
well I'll say this
they have uh 620 000 to send me so it
can't be that bad
yeah I I
thought they didn't have it I I did and
I'll tell you this bbtv
I'm very excited to announce that uh
their stock is back up uh one and a half
cents today we be TV
I think they're they recouped from the
uh earlier lost as you if you go out to
Max well I guess it's a little hard to
see there but
maybe you could do like a five day
five day
um this is what happened
it lost five cents that was a could we
do like a three day there's no like
three day option to make it look I can
do one day
okay I mean they're in the money look at
green that's 10 that's a you you guys
see that
[Music]
the moon baby bbtv
I will say this though
[Music]
while it seems like my Situation's
resolved and I'm very happy about that I
do think that
I I think that if anyone is with bbtv
they're I think gonna hopefully be just
double checking the
the uh three minutes yeah I I mean I
assume people are doing I'm just the
only idiot that somehow didn't do that
for like
three years
that's crazy I want to check
um
Zach
give me a second
[Laughter]
um uh I was oh I I said I was gonna
erase the social posts but
I'm not erasing the podcast
so I'm doing that for you now
click
she's like I didn't she's like not like
this you're supposed to just do it not
say like you're doing it
that's just not how I do it I say
everything Dan sends me messages and
Discord for me I read them out loud
it says it'd be so easy for me to
[__] destroy your life
I guess that's true that's true
not at home though
um actually and I'll tweet out that uh
it's been resolved
um
yeah but I can't I can't erase the
podcast delete the hateful tweet in
question uh well that's not how I would
exactly uh
[Music]
describe the situation but I hear you
so I guess well why don't we do a vote
you guys want to do a vote see where
people think we should go
fair enough well don't you want at least
some input it doesn't it's not binding
well listen we threw out a lot of good
ideas ultimately it's your money
wherever you want to go no no no no no I
mean well obviously I can't go to like
Japan and crazy trips like that because
it's just too time consuming I'm
thinking like a weekend maybe a long
weekend like three days
but anywhere I think the Disney World
trip ain't bad and we could turn it into
content oh yeah never been to Florida
before we certainly talk about Florida
enough I love Florida I'd love to go
there I think that'd be awesome maybe
he's gonna be in Florida in a couple
hours yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
and this is a courtesy I I told her
listen No Strings Attached but I said
I'll erase the social ones
they got the uh Avatar Land there I
think at Disney let's [__] go to
Pandora you can watch all the Avatar
films on the plane trip over there Ethan
all SWAP seats with Ila so we can sit
together and we can watch it and hold
hands
I say uh happy to announce that bbtv has
agreed to pay us back in full there you
go
so let's start planning it dude oh
somebody just pointed out
there is a Disneyland in Tokyo that's
not happening okay you gotta let that go
and they have the attack on Titan world
at Universal there you gotta let that go
you guys
sounds right personally I'm feeling
Vegas that's my vote we got it just
saying you know why exactly Vegas is
always fun but it's also it's four hours
away and I don't know about you well
we've been a million times we'd fly but
you're I Disney World is more epic I
just mean yeah it's just like we can go
to Vegas I've never been there exactly
it's a novel Adventure
it's a novel Adventure Zach can we get
Gatsby's
we got the funds yeah
[Music]
the Gatsby trained with my dream that we
all get yeah
um
we all get the disability mobility
scooters and Crews the whole thing with
a tour guide right oh my God it's so
obnoxious but it's so funny it's a
disability
I think we get canceled for that
rightfully so
but it's so funny at a certain point
it's like yeah maybe it's a little
insensitive but at the same time like
the funniness you've got to
because we would have like a whole ass
car park outside every ride it would be
so
I don't think they would allow it it's
funny
dude it's the VIP tour
because it's gonna be like so disruptive
to the other guests
and feel like they'd overrule us I
wonder if when we're on a ride if we
leave that many Gatsby's just out do you
think someone will Jack at least one
well we'll take the keys with us well
VIP yeah
we'll be VIP on the mobility scooters
yeah yeah yeah
I can get security I can get [__] for
you can do a lot with 620.
you could do a lot and there's really
nice hotels there we can stay at oh
Sam's here dude dude ranch stands
okay
I need to defend the ranch that was the
most fun trip I have ever been on Ian
knows I talk about it constantly it's so
much fun
okay when did this Ranch trip happen
uh 2018 was the last time I went so it
was a while so it was five years ago
yeah and how old are you now may I ask
I'm 25. 25. because I did river rafting
when I was a young man and it was
awesome fun I don't think I'd enjoy it
as much you will enjoy it as an adult
like when I was when I did it I was
skinny and I could like hold up my body
weight I can't even hold my body weight
think of how funny it would be if we
were all in a raft together yeah there's
water rides I think it's sound world I
think it's something no there wasn't
much you don't think you need to get too
defensive about it I don't think there
was well Ethan just didn't sound as
excited as he needed I just don't think
he understood I just don't think he
understands I just never heard of going
to a ranch yeah yeah I'm I'm with him on
that I'm not saying it's not fun but
I've never heard of that it's like a
vacation it just surprised me that's all
yeah it's it's a blast in my opinion I
don't think Disney World's bougie enough
what dude Disney World is like the
bushiest one of the boozy strip is there
people have to take like more second
mortgages on their house and take their
family there wait like you have to
literally pick out a loan to go there
I've been to Disney World before I
didn't know it was like that it's so
freaking expensive the hotels there are
insanely expensive we gotta fly there I
mean it's gonna cost me a lot less than
620 000 but where would this Ranch be
like where
I went to one in Wyoming and I loved it
I've been on a ranch Resort trip too
it's a lot of fun I'm backing up Sam
somewhere else that's right Sam's
opinion if she said it's fun then Wham
I'm for it I'm anti-wranch I'll go
anywhere there's free food I'll say I
knew I needed to defend the ranch I'm
anti-ranch I'm pro-ranch okay y'all
really want to do a ranch we could we
could do got a blank check I'm kind of
going to the ranch have you guys been to
this because I also never been to the
bar I have a really great Resort wreck
there and it's where the housewives
stayed okay past that and it's a blast
I'm down for that Bahamas would be fun
so much fun
I'm I want to go anywhere there's free
food that's awesome I got you Cam don't
worry I'm Gonna Keep Your Ass fed Yum I
want to go where they have Taco Bell and
Chick-fil-A that's everywhere they do
not have that in the Bahamas
oh so that's that's a no-go that's a V3
yeah we'll bring some on the plane oh
well anyway we can we can have this
discussion but
thanks to bbtv
we're gonna go just crazy on a crew
vacation all out it's gonna be awesome
so thank you bbtv
you've returned the money
you've done the right thing thank you
thank you bbtv they're financially
stable they're soft went up like 15
cents a day let's go
hey okay let's go it's bbtv
okay let's go
620.
hey let's do this thing okay
yeah we did we wanted to do a um
kind of a parody of the last thumbnail
or it was like
straight Warfare and then here it's like
uh Kawaii
rainbow puke
and uh
you know she's
a saint basically
but there it is
um so cool okay well I'm not very
excited about our prospective trip now
awesome
but uh actually so well that could be us
I guess that doesn't look that fun but I
don't maybe all the fun stuff is like
behind the camera we'll go Yakov dude
just behind the camera there's all kinds
of fun activities
I probably ate that yak
[Music]
sent me sent me that yak in a bag of
plastic
[Music]
well anyway
um we should probably thank our sponsors
and then I want to talk about so much
stuff we can talk about the Creator
Clash which is happening this weekend A
B is going to demolish
we're gonna put dad in a convalescent
home right AB yeah we're gonna put his
ass in hospice care that's right and the
life treatment
very soon he go to hell
uh members we're gonna be having a
members only live stream on Saturday
it's going to be so much fun we did it
last time it was a blast we'll do that
again
but okay let me thank the sponsors and
we'll get into all kinds of uh great
show we've got planned here so thank you
thank you thank you thank you too
expressvpn
let me ask you something what if there
was someone out there who kept the log
of every single thing you did every
minute of the day
that reminds me I went to Skype everyone
was trying to give me instructions on
how to uh get my Skype records and I
actually I went on the Skype website I
requested my Skype Logs with my old user
I thought it was and they're like okay
come back in the day we need to approve
it I downloaded it there was like
nothing there I was so disappointed
it was like just random
nope it was random wasn't good at all
yeah but what if there was somebody I
wish there was somebody out there
apparently
then I'd have the conversations I'm
looking for
no but we don't like that not on this
copy we don't like that what if there
was someone out there who kept the log
of everything will sing everything every
single thing you did every minute of the
day
I think that would be creepy
right
but I did ask Skype I was like do you
have every single thing I've done on the
internet that you can send me
it's creepy though
yeah well if what if I told you that's
exactly what happens every time you go
online that's true the internet
providers the real uh enemy
the internet providers allowed to store
logs of every website you've ever
visited and can legally sell this data
to anyone
that's why I always use
expressvpnnnnnnnn I don't want anybody
to know what I do on the internet
it's that crazy
now we come on we all want privacy the
fear is like what what if Russia gets
that they're gonna blackmail you
know China blackmail
no
to keep your data safe and sound
especially be on reroute your internet
connection through their secure server
so internet providers can't see or log
what you do online now many of you might
be wondering well what if routing all of
my data through a VPN then doesn't just
mean the VPN can see it
and what I'm doing and log my data
instead well you're right to ask that
many vpns claim to have a no log policy
but they've been caught logging customer
activity
expressvpn is the only VPN that I trust
because they use trusted server
technology to make sure that data is
wiped
like a crime scene like a Dexter
you don't even have to think about it
dude
they put up the tarps
the bleach there's no evidence
of any crime
uh they were the first major VPN
provider to engineer all of their VPN
service to run in Ram
this makes it impossible for the VPN
Services store any data including logs
of any expressvpn customers so it's
impossible
and you don't have to just take uh my or
expressvpn's word for it
expressvpn is so confident and there are
no log claims they even had one of the
biggest Assurance firms price Waterhouse
Cooper
audit their technology
you know about pricewaterhousecoopers
well they're the best that's like a
that's like a big ass that's like one
word too they uh hand out the Oscar
envelope I think they're legit they're
like a security firm they like run
they're like
really big deal
that's why expressvpn is rated number
one by CNET wired tech radar and
countless others
so stop letting people keep logs of what
you do online visit expressvpn.com H3
right now and find out how you can get
three months free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com slash H3
expressvpn.com H3 to learn more you know
besides the Privacy I love it because
the you can connect in other countries
and get like their whole media catalog
like my favorite example is Japan if you
do Netflix Japan
you get like all kinds of amazing
content and Anime and stuff it's like
you were there
just like you were there almost like you
were there dude sign up tonight
but anyway yeah thank you to our sponsor
please support them because uh we love
them and they support us so thank you
expressvpn and finally stamps.com we
love stamps.comstamps.com
um
I love you stamps
you know
you know I love me some stamps
the post office is a place I've spent a
lot of time in my career sending out
stuff
it's such a Time sink it's unbelievable
and stamps.com is revolutionizing how we
interact with the post office
it's better in every way
um
you know every moment every person every
dollar is going to be enhanced by using
this service they got 25 years in the
business save you time and money so you
don't have to think about it dude
exactly
here's the best part they got fat
discounts dude that you can't get
anywhere else
it's way cheaper
to use stamps.com than just go to the
post office they get like up to 86
percent off wow
because they negotiate because they have
so much business they can negotiate or
up here it is 84 off you SPS and UPS
raise
you know
it's so easy to use all you need is a
computer and a printer they send you a
free scale so you can weigh it
print the postage on your computer
you put it on the package
and here you can drop it off in a
Dropbox or you can even leave it on your
front door to be picked up you don't
have to leave the house at all oh miss
sure is right
stamps.com has been in the business 25
years and they've been indispensable for
over one million businesses I mean come
on
it's a no-brainer if you have a small
business or if you just mail a lot of
stuff
you really going to be doing yourself a
favor here set your business up for
Success when you get started with
stamps.com today sign up with the promo
code H3 for a special offer that
includes four-week trial plus free
postage and a free digital scale
there's no long-term commitment or
contracts I mean it's a no-brainer just
go to stamps.com Click the microphone at
the top of the page and enter code H3
thank you thank you to our beloved
sponsors and stamps we love stickers
we love you
um
I want to thank some people been
going kind of hard uh Kalyn Lester
thank you for the Dono for a b good luck
this weekend Oh that reminds me
somebody donated a hundred dollars for a
recent get oh it was for Garrett fish
and Garrett did we send that to him
wait was it for him no and it's all it's
all been it who was it for is for Terry
oh Terry we sent it to him or we will we
will get there the information is worth
it
sorry I walked away for a sec thank you
that's what I'm saying these people they
don't they donate and it just caught
it's like a tornado in my life
trying to get this money to people
it's not easy
what'd you say I walked away for a
second I was just saying thank you
that's 50 for you bud thank you
Nina says Gatsby for the entire crew
we can afford it BB mo money today gave
a hundred gifted BB mo money thank you
for a great great benefactor 300.
it's 300 300 yeah damn it scroll down
yet bro where who is this guy 300 DPI
thank you so much man you owe them like
and again you know it's so nice
especially now with these big donations
BB mo money thank you so much because
that means that we're gonna have more
people joining us this Saturday for our
awesome viewing party
Jess Z thank you for the nation I'll be
at Creator class so excited to see AB
fight
congrats on getting the bag back Ethan
thank you so much
check out Star Wars hotel at Disney
World
that I'm down with an improvisation you
guys want to go to Star Wars oh I seen
it it's like all the rooms are crazy
themed it looks a little isn't it
supposed to be that it's on like a
spaceship it's like a dude it's like a
star line yeah everything is like fully
on theme the rooms everything that's
cool
did you pull up pictures I think it's
like insanely expensive because the
demand is so high but I don't give a
[__] thing is they have like one of
those Katinas too for like the bars
where they sing
that's the park itself yeah probably
like the only place you can get booze at
Disneyland is at the uh actual uh Star
Wars bar that's sick yeah Disney World
and Gatsby's uh spro kepro cat says
there's lots of uh
I love how it's all it's like no it's
just a hostel with
[Laughter]
like y'all really want me to sleep in
that pod they're like luxurious living
I bet the Empire rooms are nicer so wait
is this open how much is it for a room
because I heard it was like ten thousand
a night and I'll pay that I don't care
okay
I really don't from everywhere in my
room if that check clears I'm good man
may I throw out a trip suggestion what
about a cruise I know we've talked about
it before on the show you trying to get
us killed
what cruises they're still covered I
know Ian will back me up on this one
I won't back you up on this oh wow dude
what what about our conversation wait
Zach you're the only one with positive
Cruise experience no you lost your
virginity
you backed me up didn't you I'm off of
the cruise oh my god wow Zach lost his
virginity on a cruise and uh dude
cruising is America's past time [__]
baseball that camp cruising
don't you isn't it a little weird that
you like can't escape
no you can't escape
but you're looking at water it's
gorgeous you dock places we can do one
on Mexico or the Caribbean like it's a
good time again but we only have three
days max so so just a weekend trip long
weekend long weekend trip yeah we can do
it in three days
yeah I don't think I don't I don't think
you have one supporter on that idea
it's all right I'm just standing by
myself again Zach if there's free food
I'm I'm with you all right I got Cameron
Annie Cam's like Anyway the scent of the
food blows I'll be there
it's a fine with me
thank you CeCe for the gifted appreciate
that so much so wait there's actually
like a
there's like a hologram
or some kind of display here yeah
interesting
is this for little kids it is for sure I
mean look at this it doesn't look that
nice at all not I mean it's cool it
looks cool I can Photoshop myself in
this kind of space I don't need to walk
around this is like a 5k trip
but the thing is what do you mean 5k
trip for two days it's 5K for a family
five thousand that's not that much I
mean per wait well I mean it's a lot but
not like it seems like it's more than
just a hotel though it's like you're
you're buying a whole like two-day
experience yeah thing so like if you
wanted to go to like the rest of Disney
World or whatever oh here this is the
way to do it yeah I'm not trying to like
here let's see
um Star Wars Galactic Cruiser
what does it include two guests per
cabin I sent the link that has what's
included
so it's 1200 for two or one room okay
all right guys per guess
what you pay so you pay twenty four
hundred
four thousand eight hundred and nine
oh two guys for Kevin
per guest how are you gonna charge per
guess it's one room yeah
they're like yeah how many people you
stuff it in there that's good
come on everybody in here I mean maybe
there's like a food included or you know
some type of amenities like that I think
again I think it's it's like a whole
experiential thing like here I've got
the details here it says
um packages include entry to Disney
Hollywood Studios what is that for one
day that's a park the admission ticket
expires at midnight I love that get the
[__] out midnight
non-upgradeable non-transferable
package includes two breakfasts two
lunch two dinner meals
people
yeah yeah I don't want to eat with the
Star Wars people drink like blue milk
Quick Service meal consists of one
entree one non-alcoholic beverage
or if you're over 21 you can get an
alcoholic beverage
why would I want to commit to this let
me just go buy what I want 21.
big old Star Wars nerd I guess it seems
like this is like a Super Fan Experience
you know
but can you just stay in the room
without the whole hubbub no it doesn't
seem like it that's what I'm saying I
don't think this is the way to go well
there's such nice hotels there they have
like uh Four Seasons yeah and I don't
have like bunk beds so and we can get
they always have right exactly hostile
style Japanese style pods
um they're also have like super bougie
like restaurants there that we can get
reservations for
that's what sounded pretty good to me
thank you bbtv should we legit just wear
bbtv shirts that'd be so [__] funny
they're sponsoring the trip in a way
that'd be just so funny
pictures of her face
okay cabin amenities include mini
refrigerator a hair dryer you guys
wow really yeah there's a hair dryer
it's not an up charge
is it shaped like a lightsaber look out
I'll be honest that's old Tech
right I feel like in the Star Wars
Universe they have something better it's
just done yeah in Cabin safe
I phone with voicemail with voicemail
messaging no no way you can take all
these calls that's what it says here no
way no way interactive TV what
Interactive yo they have a deal they
have a bath and shower
are there sheets on the bed it doesn't
say it doesn't say the interacting with
the TV is just Mario Lopez talking to
you about what you could order why is he
on every dude I can't see him anymore
how did he pivot to just being the guy
on the hotel TV
Mario Lopez get out of my life
and it's always on you walk into the
whole room the hotel room it's on
already
hi I'm Mario Lopez welcome
to the Hilton extra if it's Star Wars
you think it'd be a hologram of them
he's so perfect he glows he does look
amazing how old is he he's he's like old
dude he looks amazing he's he's all not
a dream tonight for sure oh he's 49.
okay not that old he's not that old but
like he looks so
good how do I look this good at 50.
glamorous stunning without even trying
it's crazy well hold on let's get a
closer look
let's take a closer look at Mario here
look at that smile the guy's got such a
oh he's still oh he's still keeping fit
he's so cool he's doing like karate and
[__]
he's got karate classes he's got that
garage
everything as karate
this man wrote a fitness book did you
know that
Mario well Mario Lopez knockout fit he's
gonna know what he's talking about
Mario Lopez Hotel TV
let's see what comes up
hi must go movies this is it must see
movies
extra
I mean in a way he it's kind of
impressive he found
a niche for himself because I mean
pivoting from Saved by the Bell not the
easiest
in fact if you look at all the casts of
Saved by the Bell
he's the only one
that still has a career
ripped a screech dude Screech is [__]
Screech bro he's dead
he's dead he's [__] dead what's his
name Dustin Diamond he [__] died
ripped him
well Mario Lopez did like X Factor and
Dancing with the Stars for a while and
then he pivoted to this uh hotel room to
be in the hotel room guy the gas station
pump Guy what's his net worth I wonder
because he's uh he's pretty good how
tall is he
oh I'll look that next Mario Lopez all
right I'll look at first dude he's 5 10
35 million he's five ten he's five ten
he's shorter than I am no way no shot by
three enough fourths away with my
three-fourths quarter of an inch
he's perfect
he's perfect for you is he a perfectly
problematic I feel like I remember him
having a scam no no that's all I know is
that he glows that's literally all I
know about Mario okay according to this
he's worth 35 million so he's perfect
that's what I'm saying
don't be don't be
discounting our boy Mario I think every
time you order a movie in hotel he gets
a kickback of that he has uh
that'd be fun
here's the crew let's see I don't know
the [__] this guy is whatever happened
to the main guy dude
look at this Mario Lopez receives a
backlash for transphobic comments on the
Candace Owens Show
Candace Owens show that's what I'm
reading yeah
perfect I take it literally all back
dude on this show anybody can catch
Strays man we started talking about
Disneyland maybe mentioned Mario Lopez
and now he's canceled and let's just
stay home dude not only stay home here
it's even worse it's even worse I just
found it send me the details I want
everything we're coming
okay the fact that he even went on you
oh my god somebody somebody stopped me
what's your argument
I got none the fact that he went on
Candace Owens on prageru means just on
face that this guy is like brain dead
Maga swamp go find someone else adult
interest listen he's just there to talk
about the importance of Family Faith and
hard work oh no not Faith look there's I
think there's nothing wrong with faith
great but when you put it in like your
description of who you are like family
and Faith then I'm like that means you
hate gay people I know what that means
you got the clip
oh I mean it's a 40-minute thing uh
amazing oh wait we have someone
co-signing for uh Mario Lopez oh we do
cared for dust and Diamond a lot still
kept in contact with him unlike the
others
according to Reyes who is a Mario Lopez
historian
that he he unlike the other stayed in
touch with Dustin
I see is that and why is
is that admirable like I don't I don't
know apparently I don't know anything I
don't know anything about no maybe
Justin's a dick I've never watched Saved
by the Bell even though that was of my
generation uh never got into that one
Justin had a huge dong massive dong oh
he had like a sex tape didn't he yeah
monster dong I don't believe you would
get him I feel like you put you give me
no no no no this guy sends me the
picture privately I'll be the judge okay
how tall is he what's his net worth how
big is his dong
wait wait wait Shanna said
wait no sorry Shanna I'll get to yours
uh pfp actually you guys you guys are
making this so hard for me to read your
names pfp achichio
says he cheated on Ali laundry at the
bachelor party and the wedding was
canceled did he really do that family
and Faith Mario Mario
can you not win can you not find that
dude somehow this just turn into one
curing Mario Lopez's life
Charizard's at home like hey at least
they ain't talking about me
oh people saying it was a stand-in Zach
you got got
no it's his daughter he admitted it was
a stand-in
that's how do you do a stand-in in a
second that's even cooler that's a word
to try and show people that his dick was
big so he had a stand-in I still I don't
believe it that's amazing I mean I'm
just going off very Mario Lopez Behavior
I don't think Screech would do the
Screech wouldn't do that Screech would
not do that
um
uh uh news Noob sandwiches I apologize
on Hawaii's behalf next time I suggest
Disney Resort for you and the crew you
know those why are you apologizing you
know those Disney people don't mess
around and Teddy and Bruce will love it
can I bring the kids
it would be cool to I mean I guess maybe
no better than us yeah I mean obviously
they'll have fun but they would love it
but
if it's like a team building thing
it would be it would just be all about
the kids
for me and Ila anyway
um
they're saying he cheated on his fiance
at a With a Stripper on his bachelor
party
that's crazy do you still want to see
this dong Ethan yes
it's a stand-in nah it's not even legit
so I guess now we know why he's on Hotel
TV oh guys listen to this Nick Clark
says if you do go to Epcot is that a
Disney yeah it's part of Disney World
they say if you go to Epcot you gotta
drink around the countries it's like
their own bar crawl challenge thing
are we loving that uh
dude I think I think Disney World's
sounding fun CeCe thank you so much for
the gift that we love cc I just uh sent
it to you on WhatsApp
let's take a look here
okay
wait whose long is it is it Dustin
Dustin Diamond yeah okay it's a picture
of
he's got the um Candy necklace around
his dick
and they're eating it off
yeah that's a pretty nice sized one I'll
admit that yeah so everybody it's not
his yeah Saved by the Bell Screech
confesses to sex tape stunt penis dude
my life is a lie yeah
there's an article from 2014 about this
um
it was a stunt wing
in his own words that's an interesting
okay
how did he die like overdose or
something he had cancer I think oh
that's just sad I'm sorry he died of
cancer that's horrible yeah I'm gonna
delete this picture from our chat yes
please okay
please erase that
anyway Marlo Lopez is apparently the
worst man ever and now uh he's canceled
can you find that can you find the time
stamp though of him talking [__] on
trans people
uh yeah I could try let's see I've been
looking it's just it's hard to find the
most boring conversation ever was
well
there it is Mario Lopez everybody
here's Mario Lopez
being baptized
in the Jordan River so I guess he found
Faith after he cheated on his uh fiance
With a Stripper
is that a good time to find Faith
spiritual moment he said maybe this is
why he's glowing is the Jesus water look
let me get baptized in Jordan River I
need a glow like that
[Music]
you're gay hey
come on they're being baptized show some
respect amazing Jordan River
uh he wanted to be baptized I think it's
funny how they stand on the water fully
clothed I don't know why I know y'all I
know you all got your own methods and
[__] and God bless you for that
the only thing you're missing is like a
baseball cap a wet baseball cap
yes I do do you believe that
if the Son of God yes I do these are
easy questions
yeah this ain't no Mensa IQ test I
thought there'd be like a quiz or
something
to serve him all your life yes I do I
mean according to your testimony I've
never seen a baptism before
I've never this is where we are this is
shocking and interesting fascinating to
me let's be respectful let's watch
are they wearing pants or swim trunks
probably swim trunks under the robes
I have no man you think that old man is
wearing swim trunks
they look ridiculous
yeah they don't bring anything
underneath yeah it's either that or
they're free balling
I think he's going free
I think it's possible I think so too you
gotta be careful with that white
clothing though where is this it's
beautiful there's the Jordan River
that's where I know but where where oh
like where is this it looks gorgeous
there
love that you want to go I do want to go
get baptized there let's do it you
accept Jesus yes
is Jesus your savior yes
is Jesus the son of God yes
do promise to serve Jesus for your whole
life yes
it's not really
oh it's in Israel
yeah he's in Israel I think it was
technically Nazareth that's where Jesus
was baptized in the Jordan River
oh man that's gorgeous I never been that
looks so nice I didn't know Israel had
like nice places like that
I mean amen
[Music]
good time to be fit with that little
see-through okay I'm not gay no more
he's got pants
[Music]
you did it such a shame that just sucks
and the minute the minute I got dunked
in that water I felt it through my bones
I hate trans people
I knew some of which a voice not water
whispered through my ears I
[Music]
I threw my whole being
it said I hate trans people
I must think and talk about trans people
every minute of every day
that's what it said to me Lord help
[Music]
so it's kind of a cool little outfit
sexy kind of put through its way
that's true beautiful people are there
he seems so I'm sorry brother he seems
so [__] fake
beautiful people out here wow great
ceremony wow like that's not somebody
who just had like a [__] spiritual
experience what please guys uh even and
next time you're in a hotel room don't
forget access the Fantastic movies
playing so like politician like the way
that he did all that
oh [__] you know when I was a kid
they had I guess it was probably some
kind of scam bordering on scam they
would send out like fly Mass Flyers to
tons of families and be like uh hey uh
come get head shots
of your kid
and will help pitch them to movie
Producers it's some stupid [__] right
and we my parents wanted to take me and
my brother's hair
so we did this whole thing where we go
and get our photo it was I did dude it's
so embarrassing that we went to that
thinking back I was just a kid it's
their fault not mine
there's just a ton of families and
everyone's in there they get the photo
you pay money and then and then at the
end of the line Mario Lopez was there
shaking your hand so you get to me as
part of this package Jill you got to
meet Mario Lopez I want to do and I met
Mario Lopez and I shake shook that man's
hand do you think he's still doing those
events I don't know because that was
that was desperate times for him I got
I'd go that was desperate desk for time
stream man
pre-hotel TV
that's right that's right
just got baptized in Jordan River can I
say that AB yeah he posts about it so he
goes to your gym your boxing gym have
you ever seen him there no I he was
downstairs once I think when I was there
but I haven't actually seen him
is downstairs like the VIP yeah
actually over the weekend was the first
time I actually went in there
yeah that's pretty cool it's for like
professional fighters professional yeah
but they gave me a free jacket yesterday
they said uh since I'm I'm technically
one of their professional fighters I
don't know if they got that a little
mixed up but I was like sure I'll take
it you're probably one of their most
famous fighters they have some big
people in there big celebrities come in
there well you are you are a famous
fighter I mean you're getting you're in
a big event yeah fighting in a big event
you know
hallelujah thank you thank you
Hallelujah
God bless you
it's just a bunch of Israelis
I guess it's a mix
nazareth's a weird town man I went there
one time and like there's just like
it's like a cult there man like the
Christians there there's not a lot of
Christians in Israel
but they're all there in Nazareth and
they're all trying to sell you like
candles and crosses and like they're all
so into it man because you know the
craziest people from around the world
they'll move to Nazareth
because they just want to feel the
presence of Jesus Lord
yes
that was awesome that was so cool and I
was so fortunate to meet these um very
nice people from Romania and father are
they sing the song for me and everything
father uh I believe his name
is
someone gonna hand him a towel
oh [__] I'm looking for a full service
baptism okay I need a towel I need some
slippers
a space heater please when it comes out
like to soak my feet before
have some tea Ready for Me By The River
High service
okay Mario Lopez
so this person says Mario Lopez is my
landlord live in the valley and he owns
my bill like terrible landlord if you
can imagine what a shock well most are
to be fair yep most dire Mario Lopez is
your landlord
so here I got the time step of him
apparently on Candace Owen show
talking about
uh trans people
you know it's funny it's like I just
it's like bro
you're the you're the Saved by the Bell
guy you do a bunch of [__] announcing
whatever
trans people you got they got nothing to
do with you
like why you commented talking [__] they
you got nothing to do with them bro I
mean why don't you just go on and be
like yeah so uh people from
I just want to say this uh
you know
people from Nebraska I [__] hate them
it's like what did they do what do
people from Nebraska got to do you ever
been to Nebraska no
you ever met a Nebraska person uh
nope
away too and um look I'm never one to
tell anyone how to parent their kids
obviously and I think if you come from a
place you should though because you seem
to be doing something
of course Candace goes
listen I'm not someone to tell how to
live their lives you should be she's so
vile I mean she her blood is black I
have a theory that she she's just a
demon
I think if if she were to cut herself
flame would spit out of it
she doesn't believe like the rest of us
something right thanks you know and I
would say if you come from a place of
love you you know you really can't go
wrong but at the same time my God if
you're three years old and you're saying
you're feeling a certain way or you're
you're you think you're a boy or a girl
whatever the case may be
dangerous is apparent to make that
determination then okay well then you're
gonna be nobody's doing that
can y'all just shut the [__] up it's
like nobody's doing that
you know
three
three-year-olds my son my son is almost
four he doesn't he doesn't even know
what gender is
three-year-olds
a boy or girl whatever the case may be
and it's it's sort of alarming and might
not happening about the repercussions
later on and uh to me I just see
depression because I when I was uh in
fifth grade I don't know it was this
weird thing in fifth grade where me and
my girlfriend Molly like we just we were
tomboys we just were like we're tomboys
now so we'd wear like that's not what
being trans is
they're just tomboys
just let them play soccer they'll be
fine
so anyway okay I guess that was it or do
they go on
these people are so annoying here's
pretty much more of that
they're so annoying like a 40 minute
thing oh he goes on and on
that's right about that I'm just saying
the interview is like 40 minutes long
but he apologized apparently he said the
comments I made were ignorant and
insensitive
and now I have a deeper understanding of
how hurtful they were okay
he wrote to the Huffington Post I have
been and always will be an arted
supporter of the LGBT community and I'm
going to use this opportunity to better
myself
and educate myself moving forward I will
be more informed and thoughtful he said
I mean the mistake he made was sitting
across a demon because she's
she's gonna make everything all visited
opinion some way crazier
he was about to be demoted to motel TV
oh no he's actually there too cam
when I couldn't find a uh a hotel for
twitchcon I had to stay at a motel and
he was there he was on the motel here
remember what motel it was it was a
Motel 6 and it was [__] scary yeah
but he made me feel a little bit more
comfortable I'm not gonna lie oh Mario
you're here I'm all right she's got a
warm face yeah okay familiar face yeah
that was a scary room I kept apologizing
to Lena I was like I thought we were out
of this phase of Our Lives I'm so sorry
it's so scary there how much was it a
night it was super expensive too Lena do
you remember how much oh no no I don't
it was pricey though because it was like
last minute and everywhere else was
booked we talking like 200 a night 309 I
think it was over 300. oh damn we had
another room and we got there and
they're like oh we don't have any rooms
yo did they pay you back yeah yeah they
reimbursed me here but did they like
compensate you for screwing you over no
stupid
yeah dumbasses idiots
all right well we've made it basically
half a percent through our document
maybe less frankly maybe less
um
well shout out Mario Lopez
he's saved he's risen so cool dude then
you're cracking me up on the Easter he's
up
he's up he's up he's up everybody will
it's almost like dad's home everybody
turn off the TV and scram
ble yeah I showed this on uh the members
stream yesterday but
I do want to show this to everybody
because if I saw it you have to also
as you guys sure this is safe to show
this is so wild I know he's wearing
pants he is wearing pants I just want to
say cam and I have meme this into
existence yeah we've been joking about
this world like said Eddie what are you
doing here with your dick out
that's a good question we we always just
make up different scenarios what are you
doing in Walmart with your dick out
exactly
and now it's unfortunately true
no okay so he is wearing he is wearing
underwear he said in the comments that
he is wearing shorts you can see it yeah
you can see he's wearing he's wearing
shorts but his fupa is doing a he's
doing a lot of work it's covering it's
consumed his pants I can say that I know
what that's like yeah
and it looks like he's butt ass naked
I'm hesitating to show it I I don't want
this to jeopardize but it's so good I
feel like I have to uh
I don't know you couldn't you could
tweet it
can direct people there or something can
you put an overlay saying he is wearing
pants because so the YouTube Raiders
they'll be like he's wearing pants
just so they know is it gonna click it
and it'll be like he's wearing pants
because that's fine if he's wearing
pants there's nothing wrong with that
there is something wrong with this
but if he's you know what I mean can you
do that Ian
I'm making something right now yeah we
could just get that on
dear YouTube
he's wearing pants
Eddie what are you doing here with your
dick out well I just love having my dick
out cause I'm ready that's a beautiful
day I just love having my dick out you
know Alan dershowitz is a nudist so I'm
Eddie mine is Dick's out my dick's out
too we love Eddie of course but this
definitely shocked the hell out of me
thank you
this is [__] crazy I made it love it
it's still up on Tick Tock they never
removed it so it can't be that bad yeah
I've Tick Tock didn't remove it they'll
remove anything
he had another Banger
um when he was in Walmart uh he meets
these two people and it was the most uh
Havoc inducing uh Tick Tock he's made
I feel like we gotta show that one the
his
are you talking about the like craziest
uh people he's found in Walmart yeah
yeah yeah
okay here we go yeah pull that one up
too we'll watch it next
so here's a little uh shirtless Eddie
update he's uh pantless Eddie now
For Better or Worse
and he is wearing pants I want that
emphasized
in fact you can see it
oh here I'm pulling it up
here it comes
here's Eddie's and we're gonna have to
mute it
yeah yeah but he's slip sinking to
something
yeah I mean this scared me I'm not gonna
lie I just scared me it's something
about the filter
oh [__] me I'd [__] man Buffalo he is
wearing he is wearing pants so I'll just
play it for you
[Music]
laughs
yeah you can see the pants there see
there it is he's wearing like uh denim
some kind of like denim short the other
way is covering there yeah the overlay
was covering the most egregious uh part
of the frame so huh the the overlay it
was covering the part that probably
would have got us demonic oh good yeah
so I think he's wearing pants yes but
now what if they think he's not wearing
pants because it's covered
he is wearing pants I promise don't you
anyway
uh so yeah that's what Eddie's up been
up to and we love that for him he's out
there uh
I don't really know how to put to think
about that
would be to be totally honest
um
I don't know I don't know hello
it's slightly upsetting it's like yeah
it's slightly upsetting you know not
anything against Eddie but uh
Buffalo Bill Vibes I prefer I think I
prefer shirtless Eddie to pants sure
with uh with some shorts on yeah dick
out Eddie guys he has lost a lot of
weight yes he has looking good
that's true that's true
when you're right you're right here's
the other uh Eddie video that was kind
of worth watching here
you found it founded some really
interesting characters
you do it in Walmart with your shirt off
put your shirt back on hey Eddie yo so
this guy scared the [__] out of me
I legit I my brain went into like shock
and confusion because his face looks
like some kind of AI generated or some
kind of super filter
Ben Kingsley with a filter on oh my God
you're right
I I swear to God my brains panicked and
like what are you doing I almost had a
stroke or something it looks like Vince
that person looks like Vince Neil from
Motley Crue shirt off man
like his eyes are so wide open and the
drawn on eyebrows
although he's wearing a super hype
hoodie
I think he's so soft-spoken to this guy
I think that's a mirror
mirakami hoodie that if it's original
that's probably super expensive
maybe he's rich
Eddie put your shirt back on what are
you doing okay
hey Eddie what are you doing in Walmart
with yourself oh he's in English what
are you doing with your shirt off Eddie
hey don't talk with your nips out don't
talk
when you got your nips you want to float
them my shirt I said don't count with
your nips out when you're in a Walmart
show off those nips
thank you so much I love you are you um
I love how he shows him picking up his
shirt thank you so much I love you are
you um uh Tick-Tock at all or no okay
well thank you so much
I can send it
fantastic I like the emphasis on nipples
shirts out nips out shirts out
get your nipples out the emphasis on the
nipple I think maybe is a little also
making me a little uncomfortable
like the shirt Part I
you know I I have some feedback for him
Eddie what are you doing here with your
nips and dick out
I love having my nipples out
it's out nips out so yeah Eddie's been
busy we wish him well of course he's out
there
shirtless as ever
is this right Nick acoto says he's
changed his mind and wants to come back
on the show oh yeah
okay it's great news so so are we still
on the nicocado train we've never left
the nicocado train
I don't think you ever left the nick of
Carter tree it was just a misunderstood
does that mean he forgives me for well
he basically here watch the clip okay
he was doing a q a
cheers
[Music]
please don't eat that wait that looks
good wait that looks good
before we watch this video
what was a great start I would like you
to think carefully about whether you
want an episode of nicocado avocado
coming on the show to actually happen or
not I do yep you do yeah I do okay I'd
be fantastic I always take that thought
yeah keep it right here
right at the front of yeah as we watch
this video because you could easily
change that okay and all right before so
I will update everybody on my status uh
as we move on we'll check in
periodically okay I don't see that he
could say anything that I wouldn't want
him on the show like I'm very proud
doesn't have anything to do with what he
said no what he says is a great
something to do with what you say okay
all right let's see
[Music]
I
went up to get the watermelon
do people even want I feel like it's
such old stale beef are you not even
beef
there's really no beef it is what it is
but
people still are asking me go on the H3
podcast yeah I mean yes it would be
great it would be a great show I feel
like we would have a
I mean I have so many questions for him
as a person he's fascinating I'm not are
we gonna do this whole [__] thing
where I gotta buy him a ticket then he
cancels and he gets a free ticket again
because I'm not loving that idea maybe
you got to pay for your own goddamn
ticket this time dude we bought you a
first ask first class ticket we couldn't
get a refund on
he offered to pay it back
he did oh I forgot I forgot he said he
wanted to oh okay okay then I forgot I
forgot I forgot so never mind that
that's 100 so he was gracious in that
then 100 yeah yeah he wanted to make it
all right and we said okay okay don't
worry about it okay okay okay
that's my bad I just forgot I forgot
why is Shredder dying of kidney disease
and nicocado is fine
[Laughter]
it's just not fair
it's just not fair we will never meet
nickano
I'm just not fair
[Music]
thank you
do you guys actually care enough to I
mean it's been like this happened a year
or two ago like we're still talking
about it
I got over it I mean
do you guys want me to
yes tell them I mentioned them earlier
in this video to like scroll back and
tell them I said hi
and um
it is what it is I mean I don't know do
they even want me I think it's oh I
think they don't like me
most definitely welcome and I most
definitely do like him
any any any
animus that was uh perceived between us
is honestly it's nothing but love I I
genuinely mean that you know I don't
I don't think so
welcome and I I changed my mind and I
don't know but people keep like how many
people are asking me on Twitter will you
go on the podcast where you go on the
podcast what do you see Ethan
it's
dang people are so intense about it
people want it I I I get it it would be
really yeah
Olivia is one of those people literally
the collab of the century I think I
think it'd be the funniest thing ever
half those Twitter accounts he's talking
about are Olivia's alts for I left a
mess I left a question for him I said
how are you so skinny
I found out my brother is also a big fan
of Nick no way yeah that way yeah okay
love him I mean I'm just kidding though
like I mean I he I don't expect that he
would be upset about the kidney joke I
don't I think in in person probably he
wouldn't because he'd be here to reply
getting him in person I haven't changed
I mean the item had changed into three
months since the last time I said the
mean stuff about him that I won't repeat
you know what I mean yeah I think it was
the fact that you two weren't speaking
directly to each other yeah I think that
you guys in the same room it'll do
something very special
I I agree I I but it's all love it I
swear to God it's all love
Nick I will literally push your
wheelchair if you want one I will
literally carry you up the stairs if you
want me to I'll do whatever to make sure
you have a beautiful trip someone said
this is the most sane I've seen him
actually I agree he's being
interestingly genuine here what did you
expect me to think he's being really
genuine right now
me yeah I was just you misunderstand I
just know you and every time you talk
about Auto you say something that I see
I misunderstood what you're saying
you're saying don't say what like
something about the kidney joke so that
he'll come up right I see what you're
doing in a way I kind of blame Dan for
that moment because he if he wouldn't
have said anything I think you might
have got through it hell I took that
this exact opposite you tempted him I
thought you were saying it could be
ready I was saying because the whole
first time fell apart because you kept
making comments that upset him and then
he bailed so I was trying to say if you
want the guy on when you watch it you
should have been more more clearer well
because I interpret that the exact
opposite way
all right
I'm kidding I thought you were like he's
really gonna piss you off in this one
what was it that I said
anyways shout out to Ethan Klein shout
out to Nick picardo
Jesus man
the neighbors upstairs are playing
trombone again
I love how he has talky blue talkies all
over his his hand that he's scrolling on
his phone with just the cherry on top
he's perfect
this is hell for me being forced to eat
this meal I
am so good honestly it's like Mexican
street corn
dipped in demons juice with Taki blue
[__] demon poison well maybe you guys
will have to try it together
yeah they'll knock till you try it yeah
but yeah it's all love it's all love is
that all what he had to say I mean yeah
let's reach out let's reach out again
I'll send him a message right now
I'm still interested uh it is old beef I
agree but the beef isn't what's
interesting I never thought it was that
I thought it would be
our interview genuinely
let me message him or do you have his
email right Dan
I do I feel like Olivia's the person to
put on point are you in contact with him
I'm not but I can try to be nope that I
can make an introductory it's happening
yeah Cece
and me what was his name for you Olivia
he
you can say Ashley AKA Olivia yeah right
but CC me and Olivia let's make this
happen Nick all right Hello Olivia
fun exciting
oh yeah you know uh previously we were
debating Ryan Kavanaugh's Rotten Tomato
average score and it turns out that it
was wrong and I'm happy to say that
a fan and member of the subreddit
actually
put the work in
crunch the numbers in Excel to get his
average Rotten Tomato score
they said I made a spreadsheet detailing
an average Tomato Meter score
all of Ryan Kavanaugh's movies something
interesting I came across was that if
you consider the average of these scores
equivalent to American college classes
kavcaf would only have only ever had
three movies out of 73 whose average
scores were above average
49 of his movies also flopped at the
boss box office that was the problem
yeah that's that's definitely that's
what an issue yeah
so too long didn't read Ryan's Tomato
movie average is 40 out of 100. damn for
critics
not good
average score
that's critic scores 40. that is not
good angry
thank you for putting the work in there
friend
appreciate it thank you
so let's see there's a few uh main
stories I want to get to we got the Ohio
bus driver
incident is everyone seems pretty
excited to talk about that I did want to
touch on the Chris from Mr Beast coming
out as non-binary
I want to voice my support for him and
all the freaking the freaks
Who come out of the woodwork Dalai Lama
asking a boy to suck his tongue
that was crazy Grandpa's feeling a
little frisky today Kid Rock no
so let's let's just let's just get right
into it
no not like that Kid Rock
being a little frisky today suck on my
tongue my tongue oh no there's a sound
drop
oh no and he said it in English Play It
Again
my tongue bro
that sound drop oh my God
that's AB horrible that's
um
[__]
play it one more time
there's really no way to let's just talk
about that since we're on that Dalai
Lama
what's the Dalai Lama controversial at
all before or was he just like
universally loved
uh he's the leader of Tibet
right The Reincarnation of Buddha or
something like that
he's the exiled leader of Tibet
um he
uh is in Exile from the Chinese yeah the
Chinese want to kill it
and he's been the Dalai Lama I believe
since like the 30s
um is that right cam since he was born
yeah I think they no I think I think I
think they he was chosen as an
adolescent at like eight or nine years
old or something like that I don't think
they do it from birth
um he's he's supposed to believe uh to
be the 14th Reincarnation of a
bodhisattva yeah and and he's seen by
some people as you know uh there's a
whole free Tibet movement and he is seen
as sort of the uh political and
spiritual leader of that
um there is a lot of controversy in some
circles because of course
um you know it's all highly political
stuff and he's very outspoken I would
say in the in the West in America in
particular uh yeah mostly universally
like I mean the talking I've seen of him
I've enjoyed he seems smart and
thoughtful and interesting
but now when you see this it makes me
wonder like
it's another religious guy
getting too close with little boys
and it's just making me think like him
too is it him too I don't know
let's watch I mean you I don't know it's
it's hard it's tough I liked the Dalai
Lama's as little as I knew about him
so the back story is
he was giving a speech
and this kid I guess was like uh
wanted to come up and give him a hug
because he was so moved by the Dalai
Lama so he let him come up and give him
a hug and this is what happened
but this is already like
why your lips so puckered up
he's 87 dude that's old as hell boy
[Music]
Joe Biden moment
this kid's regretting going up there
he's like [__] I take it back
um
can you still like
can you still be like a nasty old man at
87 like do you I still have feelings of
like
so old
he was gonna he was gonna do it so I
guess they stopped him
foreign
he did not suck his tongue
I mean it looks to me like this is a guy
who's like old and kind of forgot where
he was
I feel like
I don't know I hate it I hate it so much
is this like is it I wonder if there's
going to be more coming out about the
tongue-sucking Dalai Lama
God
uh some Tibetans say that Dalai Lama
suck my tongue bar videos being
misinterpreted sticking one's tongue out
can be a form of greeting in Tibet but
that she that's a crucial difference
right between sticking the tongue out
and sucking the tongue my tongue
for example I take my penis out to go
pee
but there's a big difference between
taking it out
I don't know where that's going and
sucking it yeah not big difference
oh brother so he had the issue an
apology
uh he said
he tweeted out let's see
a video clip has been circulating that
shows a recent meeting when a young boy
asked his Holiness the Dalai Lama if he
could give him a hug his Holiness wishes
to he's got to change his name to his
creepiness his horniness yeah
his horniness
his Holiness wishes to apologize to the
boy and his family as well as his many
friends across the world for the hurt
his words may have caused
his Holiness often teases people he
meets in an innocent and playful way
even in public and before cameras he
regrets into the bed
and it just it makes bro I'm sorry it is
so the the [__] Notes app apology
from the Dalai Lama that's so [__]
funny like
it's just so weird
oh they have context the teasing that
Dalian was referring to
those sticking ones tongue out is
Tibetan form respect that doesn't
involve sucking
we got the correction here under Dalai
Lama's apology
bro I hate that
oh this man's been alive
for 87 years and he [__] it up
dropped the ball he was almost out he
tripped at the Finish Line he was almost
out he tripped right at the Finish Line
exactly what happened he [__] his pants
at the Finish Line he was gonna you know
he was gonna send to Nirvana
now he's gonna get reincarnated as a
[__]
June bug or some [__]
I don't like this I don't like I don't
know how I really I I I I feel so
disillusioned
if this really
is something he's been doing
it's like there's no escape from these
people it's like they're infiltrating at
every level it's so it's so freaking
scary and weird it's just weird too like
why are there so many of them
so scary and weird the Dalai Lama's up
to the [__]
and even if it was at its most innocent
just a joke
like that just a joke doesn't work for
Shane Dawson it doesn't work for the
Dalai Lama either you know what I mean
when you're playing around with kids
exact yeah right totally I mean I I
it's a joke he goes now suck my tongue
what's the joke is that
what is the joke yeah exactly
suck my tongue
that's wild man I can't
so there it is
I
Dalai Lama ladies and gentlemen
I'm I see a lot of people say in the
chat I'm sure you saw too that those
photos of him at the Nexium event yeah
but you can pull that up yeah you know I
saw this I I looked into it it was it
was when they were known as a quirky
group but it was many years before all
this big scandals about them broke out
so you can't totally
for that I don't think I I when I saw
that I just assumed it was like one of
like a thousand speaking meeting
engagements he had when he was touring
America you know what I mean yeah no I
think he was like
you know fairly
complimentary of their it was you know
it was because it was just like a
self-help new age
group at the time you know what I mean
well it wasn't but that's that's what it
was known as Keith tell me more about
your
about this branding I really like that
tell me more about the uh
the blackmail I find that fascinating
I'd seen the Dalai Lama speak in person
before was it great uh it was cold it
was a cold day it was at Gillette
Stadium where the Patriots played so I
thought that was interesting but I spoke
to the whole stadium wow yeah he spoke
to the whole state was it good
um
I mean it was entry-level World Peace
stuff you know okay it was nice to hear
okay he didn't suck anybody's tongue
right that's good yeah I was a little
kid at the time when I saw it too so it
was cool the next thing I'm seeing was
in May of 2009 so that's a long time
long time ago yeah yeah
uh first major expose on Nexium was in
2017. so this was nearly a decade before
yeah they were publicly known so that's
uh sex cult Kevin my mortal enemy said
keep at it Ethan one day you'll be half
the man Jason
why are you watching I don't even
understand why you why do you watch
[__] hey dude
this guy's just torturing me that's
rough
all right so there's the Dalai Lama
his horniness his
creepiness
speaking of old grandpas oh yeah let's
do that Kid Rock
Kid Rock Yelp I don't know if y'all saw
this it's part of
can you give us your best uh bow with
the bow
the bang the bang he's the bow bow
bang the main guy
yeah I did I'm not doing that do it he's
got a white Maga hat too he's like wait
power
yep
[Music]
did I see the words right I mean I don't
know just a bunch of gibbles enough yeah
I'm embarrassed to say I know all the
words to that can you because it's it's
was popular in Michigan at least is he
from Michigan
give me just give me a little bit if you
don't mind I'd rather die come on hey
you you put that information out there
don't leave us hanging you can just
speak sing it you don't have to what's
this song called
bow bow it bow it
Diggy said the Boogie set up jump the
buggy
and then so here it goes ready my name
come on baby
my name is
Kid Rock oh it's just more of this so
here's the verse
and this is for the questions that I
don't know the
the Rhythm that glancers in the top of
his dance there's the can of freaks cars
packed with speakers the G's with 40s
and the chicks with beepers
[Applause]
and the bong to the diggy diggy diggy
diggy baby's actually a walking out to
the song at a Creator class yeah that'd
be interesting choice
uh so anyway here's Kid Rock he's
talking about
I don't know if we've talked about this
but
light spot did like a campaign with a
trans person
and
every uh conservative [__] bag
grifter
uh lost their mind
because apparently trans people aren't
allowed to drink Bud Light like what is
their point trans people no Bud Light
for you trans they don't like because
it's being shoved in their faces it's
being shoved you don't have faces it's
just it's like it matters what's on the
side of the can that I'm drinking it
matters it's not for you
trans people need to drink Michelob
straight people drink straight
binary people you know they I think they
feel like Bud Light is a you know
ingrained part of like American culture
and
um seeing seeing it Go woke is uh
literally especially triggering to them
because yeah you know
most of their identity is based off of
products and things that they consume
and Bud Light is that's a key one man
that's that's iconic Bud Light is that's
the beer you know what actually I've
never swatched this video so
it was just this one video as I
understand it well and the overall
campaign itself with uh Dylan Mulvaney I
don't know anything about her yeah they
made um they made cans with her face on
it too okay right right okay happy March
Madness that's a football thing right
just basketball basketball just just
found out this had to do with sports and
not just saying it's crazy about in
celebration of sports thing Bud Light is
giving you the chance to win 15 000
share this video
so she's just working on a campaign with
them it's not even really that big of a
deal so they all
uh Mass trans hysteria let's watch the
video see how offensive is it
got some Bud Lights for us
this thing called March Madness and I
thought we were all just having a hectic
month but it turns out it has something
to do with sports and I'm not sure
exactly which sport but either way it's
a cause this is like a really weird
campaign for them only because
she doesn't I don't know if it's stick
but it she doesn't even know about
basketball
uh also apparently a small correction
they didn't even sell the cans it was
just a marketing thing they sent her
cans with her face on it as like a you
know as a marketing thing that she could
take photos with and everything they
probably do like a hundred of these
every month right these little mini
campaigns with influence yeah here
here's a photo of the can thank you Cam
thank you Cam
thanks for the can okay
so she's got like a one of a kind yeah
it's just like kind of a fun little
thing okay they kind of did a dirty too
this unflattering illustration over in
my opinion
uh it yeah it's a little too much too
much shading yeah
celebrate
this month I celebrated my day 365 a
Womanhood and Bud Light Sent Me possibly
the best gift ever a can with my face on
it check out my Instagram story to see
how you can enjoy March Madness with Bud
Light and maybe win some money too love
ya
so they watch this and they go [__] oh
[__] and they call they call Lib
snowflakes
they went home and they beat their wives
yeah we know we know that they slam
their kids into the wall
they get got drunk and started shooting
their guns in the air
[__] why God
America is falling
was just in Nashville Derek says and
passed by Kid Rock's Restaurant they had
Budweiser signs all over there of course
they did yeah I mean they're not gonna
they're not gonna touch Bud Light you
know my my response to this is because
when you think about light you probably
would assume their customer base is
probably pretty conservative although I
think Bud Light is popular I think it's
just for everyone that's the thing it's
just such a it's just standard issue
beer in America everybody likes Bud
Light or drinks Bud Light
but I think it was pretty cool of them I
think it was pretty uh courageous of
them during this whole trans Hysteria
to kind of do this campaign with a trans
person
um I think that was I think it's cool I
think it's cool so Chris Rock obviously
disagrees so here's Chris Rock's
response to
uh that is Kid Rock it was like Chris
Rock really how disappointing The Rock
here's Rock something Rock his cousin
foreign
Grandpa's feeling a little frisky today
Grandpa's looking like he's got a liver
disease
[Laughter]
Grandpa looked like he got some jaundice
or something not looking great this
man's been drinking too much I'm sorry
this is offensive but that is the most
Michigan looking face I've ever seen
that looks like my grandfather it really
does
also what's going on with this it's like
he's been drinking lead water for too
long he had the Flint water you know
maybe this is good for him Kid Rock will
stop drinking uh beer you know yeah no
fair enough yeah maybe this is good for
yourself
grandpa is feeling a little frisky today
oh I don't like when Grandpa feels
frisky we all know bad things happen
when Grandpa feels frisky right
especially
especially this Grandpa right Zach what
happens when Grandpa feels frisky yeah
oh that's so [__] up and gross but Kid
Rock
that's you let me uh say something to
all you and B
as clear and concise as possible
[__] Bud Light and [__] Anheuser-Busch
have a terrific day so he says he wants
his message to be as clear as possible
and
frankly I don't find it very clear not
super clear he's shooting his butt like
as he hasn't said why he's upset yeah
just say it just say it if you hate
trans people or whatever you're not
being clear I want you to be more clear
tell me
do you think he went out and bought all
those Bud Light cans too for the message
oh for sure you think yeah definitely
yeah that what Amy just said in the chat
is a great Point too I was thinking the
same thing he emptied the whole mag and
didn't even knock them all off the table
like he like sprays from like 20 feet
away
and only the middle case goes down I
will say that uh thanks to uh Dylan
Mulvaney
um we're gonna see uh the sharp decrease
in liver diseases thank you to that one
post so congratulations to her doing a
real public service
we got some we got is there an issue oh
you're okay it's yeah just something
back there yeah
have a terrific day
also the message isn't clear in that he
what is is he implying that people
should be shooting guns
like his message is very not clear is
this a call for violence because I could
you could easily see it that way
are we who are we who are you sure you
know what I mean let's just um let's be
more clear Kid Rock dummy idiot it's
actually disturbing got 212 000 likes
and uh 11 million views
so this is what conservative America is
up to
do you see Crowder's reaction
no I'd love to I have it it's number
nine in the writer be so concerned about
uh grooming kids
should maybe take a look at some of his
song lyrics here
oh here's this is Kid Rock some ladies
young ladies young ladies I like them
underage see
some say that's statutory but I say it's
mandatory he released a song when he was
30 years old
wait hold the phone hold the phone hold
the phone we've talked about this on the
uh I think we brought up on leftovers
like over a year ago uh last time he was
in the news for some [__] [__] phone
man what song is this
uh what is it called it's called it was
from Osmosis Jones It's called cool yes
it's called cool daddy cool and it's
from uh the Osmosis Jones soundtrack
hold the phone which is a children's
film with that he wrote a song for about
how he likes to [__] underage girls
hey ladies and very concerned about
grooming wait wait wait wait this is
quite quite incredible those lyrics
does the Dalai Lama have thoughts
you want to spit a verse
that's a fire verse actually yeah
[Laughter]
all right let's watch Crowder so Bud
Light got even gayer if you can believe
it
Steven you just suck a dick bro you're
gonna love it like you're just every
it's just you're gonna love it man
fight like hell
these people are so pathetic
they're so insecure
how is it that people like this
it's mostly men men are so unfuckable
they're like they go nobody loves me
yeah no [__]
look at what you do with your time you
watch Stephen Crowder of course nobody's
gonna love you
if you want to get a girlfriend watch
this show
so true
I don't know if it's gay gender or
whatever Dylan Mulvaney uh did a special
can marking uh his one year anniversary
of Womanhood let's look at that phrase
his one year of Womanhood and uh this is
making grounds whatever team you love I
love too
okay
love ya okay break a leg there's one way
to curb underage drinking
I don't get it
what that's one way to the curve uh
because nobody will want to drink it
anymore nobody will want to drink
because uh she's scary wait he really
thinks that young people care about this
like you're so out of touch
that's what he means
wow
I'm surprised they even got what he was
trying to say they're like
let's also put a picture this man's
wearing a shirt that says Jesus is risen
change my mind
I've changed my mind Jesus is risen
changed my mind brother
he hasn't
he hasn't that's that's my argument
Jesus is down oh Jesus he's down
you changed my mind you've proved to me
Jesus is up just like what what are we
arguing about changed my mind baby
we both have equal amount of evidence so
Shredder's cute and I love him change my
mind
what's your argument these guys are such
Doric ass losers it's just crazy that
they're watching like the most
inoffensive clip ever of a girl just
being so nice and saying whatever team
you like I like too and then they just
are the meanest people ever like how do
they not see that that person is nice
and you are being mean so true that's
just so well said like literally she's
minding her own business drinking her
beer
she's like they act like she's like
drink this beer and then go talk to your
children and get started give them
hormones against their will we're going
to start a trans Army and we're going to
overthrow the government the first trans
Army is coming
Jesus says risen
let's also put a picture of her by the
mantle keep the kids away from the fire
yeah him shoot whatever whatever wait
wait wait he said keep them away
again
his jokes are not good
adorable look what he's saying she's
scary so they'll keep the kids by the
fire crowd are your kids dumb so [__]
dumb they don't know to stay away from
fire
they need deterrent like what kind of
dumbass children are you raising
shoot whatever whatever Z fire yes
mantle keep the kids away from the fire
yes hymns shoot
it's like so
it's it's not even funny it's like
confusing
whatever whatever Z I don't know you can
admonish me off the bat because I can't
keep this straight it's her it's not
that complicated it's just not
complicated it's so [__] hard
but
it's really so easy here's the thing we
can't confirm that you were saying
asking me this earlier we can't confirm
if this person is actually officially a
Bud Light uh partner sponsor
um because it didn't seem like it was on
Bud Light anywhere right yeah but
Mulvaney you guys I see you guys did
lots of research here in preparation for
this
yeah we didn't look into this at all
but let me tell you this
Bud Light is gay as hell now boys we
ain't drinking it
I got a friend he was drinking a bunch
of Bud Light he was sucking dick by the
end of the week boy
they putting something in that Bud Light
men are looking more and more nice to me
every day
scary to me
hi alfredo
as endorsement deer deals with Major
Brands you have Crest you have evolution
of smooth you have instacart you have
sarave you have Ulta beauty you have
native some people have said KitchenAid
I don't know if I can confirm so he's
angry that she has a career
mm-hmm I mean
yeah lots of there's like influencers
work with brands
so so he wants the world to
reject her entirely
he doesn't want her to exist essentially
and give him all of all of her success
he wants to do the Bud Light commercials
let him do it
right
uh he's the feeder kid he's the actor
here it bothers him because there's a
lot of effort to misgender her on
purpose yeah that's what it is from chat
he tried to misgender her and fail it's
that easy right someone else said he was
like [__] I was just respectful
whoops
my tongue tongue
from that and to be fair to Bud Light I
mean it was easy to trick people because
Mulvaney was their second choice you
know the first choice that we had uh Bud
Light
[Music]
huh
uh wow
dude what the [__] who is watching this
dude nobody laughed when they saw that
what is this Buffalo Bill Buffalo Bill
is that a gay guy no it's the uh villain
from Silence of the Lambs
so but so what's the joke he's not gay
if they're sponsoring it's just saying
sponsoring a trans person is like
sponsoring a serial killer well
I guess the character of Buffalo Bill
like dresses up as a woman and skins
people
um I don't understand the comparison
it's so stupid no it's ridiculous it's
so dumb why are you like this Stephen
Crowder how do you how are you
successful
[Music]
it's in the same vein
look I guess if uh so they they fired
the little leprechaun sidekick and
replaced them with this guy who the [__]
even is this
I missed the leprechaun yeah I miss him
too
and the fans do too every time I go uh
all their comment section is uh where
the [__] is Dave why'd you get rid of
Dave oh it's his dad yo that's his dad
oh that's uh the end of the show so his
dad is his manager right I had quite a I
had quite a few exchanges with uh that
man as a matter of fact wait what
happened with Crowder's dad I forget he
was the one that set up our whole thing
with Sam Cedar Oh Daddy
daddy you [__] up I wonder if he got
mad at his dad his daddy manages him
that's that's that's who I was dealing
with I wonder if his dad elbowed the
leprechaun out
foreign
took his place
look I guess if Bud Light can pretend to
be beer she can he can pretend to be a
woman yeah exactly yeah they think yeah
we need a spokesperson who knows nothing
about sports
and doesn't understand the Democracy oh
hold on Abe's leaving he's going first
he's going for his flight to Crater
clash it's happening
oh sure you could say goodbye yeah my
camera's frozen I was walking over here
to Zach but uh yes love you all thank
you guys uh and uh hopefully I will make
the family proud see you soon
baby you'll make us proud no matter what
AV yeah your older Tomatoes probably you
already made us proud kick some ass we
love you you're gonna you're gonna
destroy him dude
[Music]
[Applause]
have a good flight
[__] all the dads Crowders and the one
you're fighting
it's Rogan Amy Schumer commercial
Spotlight for well yeah those work like
a charm yes
but but my question was that really her
head why did her head look dude you're
blowing it you suck already
huge and her torso looks so tiny well
that's what happens the estrogen sort of
it breaks down the body to the point of
no repair but you still have the
economics the guy at one point yeah it's
happening
where did that chip come from
wait what can I see what he ate
where did he get this
where the hell did you get this right
here it's like a tortilla chip
or what does that smell like to you
Shredder got a chip I don't know how but
he's on like a super strict diet because
of his kidney condition
where do you find these things man
Geez Louise
you want me to believe this still is
yeah is he does he say more because I
could I could skip this whole stupid
thing was that it
we got the idea yeah boring L we got the
idea
so uh and shout out to Bud Light they
defended their partnership with Mulvaney
in a statement
they said work they work with hundreds
of influencers across Our Brands as one
of many ways to authentically connect
with audiences
that actually is the perfect statement
they're like why are you all tripping
balls about some dumb [__] idiots kid
rock dumbass
Kid Rock uh who is uh
can I call him a p word not really How
would how can we refer to Kid Rock from
that lyric feeling a little frisky today
in my opinion statutory r wordest
sure my opinion that's definitely pedo
territory
or definitely no doubt yeah again uh 30
years old he was 30 and okay so so Kid
Rock known known pedophile could I say
that I mean it's just a song lyric lots
of people put things in songs that they
don't really mean that said I have no
issue personally in my opinion believing
that he's probably a b word
it's well it's a Kid Rock he can't ever
grow up he just wants to be a kid he's a
kid he's a kid he wants to [__] kids
[Music]
[Applause]
so there it is uh there it is their
whole there's been like a whole culture
War over Bud Light sponsoring a trans
person it's actually so gross you know
the anti-trans rhetoric on the right
is becoming so hysterical it's it's so
dangerous and actually it's so sad
because trans people really are like the
the most vulnerable like the the mo one
of the most vulnerable if not
us groups and it's like it's just so sad
but it's [__]
evil dude
when we have at a minimum like a year
and a half more of this because
this is quite literally the Republican
strategy to get elected in 2024. I just
think this is like [__]
and so uh hopefully it won't work and
they'll eat [__] and then they'll find
something else I don't think Trump has a
chance in hell he already lost once it's
like
he's not better off than he was last
time
well never
underestimate the Democrats ability to
[__] it up right it never underestimated
um
it's incredible how many legitimate
problems are in this country and that a
whole party's platform is just trans
people huh like and them trans people
that's wild huh
foreign we're like well what about
health care and Medicare going bankrupt
and national debt and inflation trans
people are wild huh
yes sir trans people are wild he got a
good point
that man speaking to my soul trans
people are wild I don't understand that
at all
uh can you hand me a bottle of water
love there's too much lead in the water
today
the local government said the mayor said
don't drink water for a week it's got
too much mercury in it anyway trans
people really are the problem
hey uh sweetheart can you get me that
n95 there's too much vinyl chloride in
the air this day and that's the real
irony is like they've Juiced up their
own audience so much with this [__] that
they can't even get them to give a [__]
about that other stuff because they
tried because you remember what the Ohio
uh uh train wreck stuff uh nobody cared
they well right somewhat correctly
pointed out how little the Democrats
were doing and giving a [__] about it
Trump went there right and they were
really leaning into it and I just don't
think that they got the juice that they
want because their own audience doesn't
give a [__] about real problems and it's
awesome they I mean I think they know in
their hearts it's like we're not gonna
[__] do anything about this we we're
for deregulating all these railroads and
everything so you know they want the
Optics of like we're here to help but
they're not actually going to do
anything and it's it's much easier to
just keep harping on these culture War
things like that that's that's all they
got that's all they got to say at this
point yeah Nancy I just got back from
Urgent Care they said uh
got a I can't get afford to get my
cancer removed so anyway I'll book about
about two weeks left anyway this trans
person really right so wild
yeah yeah my son has curable blindness
my 12 year old boy got curable blindness
I just can't afford the three thousand
dollar procedure but them trans people
really messing up Society Boy hey here's
a chat message I just saw that's
heartening can't believe I was a mug
Club wow shout out to the trans fam
I almost don't believe it but if it's
true Jake I [__] love that man
I believe it good for you dude I think a
lot of their uh
a lot I think a lot of their fans are
young I think Stephen Crowder in
particular really appeals to that
[__] contrarian annoying ass
15 year old kid you know what I mean I
mean his world view Crowders worldview
was so shallow that once you have like
any level of critical thinking or
intelligence you'll see that like starts
to fall not real quick there's nothing
there yeah
that's right so anyway uh as since we're
talking about
the issue of gender
uh I did want to talk about this because
it was pretty interesting Mr Beast is
one of his best friends and crew members
I've met him sweet guy Chris Tyson
he had his son around the same time we
had Theodore
when did you meet I didn't so I was in a
Mr Beast video you remember that oh I do
remember that yeah oh okay the driving
across the country to have a burger with
H3 I remember
we're dogs
so he's a really nice guy he's always
been a really nice guy
so I guess he
started a hormone replacement treatment
he by the ways people keep getting like
Angry like a misgender he's
his uh pronouns are not he says he's
cool with whatever he has any pronouns
listed in uh their Twitter I mean his
name is Chris still so
well Chris is actually
kind of a neutral yeah you're right yeah
just put a K in there and then all of a
sudden
but anyway uh I know him I like him you
know so
stop that
oh look I didn't know that this uh
let's see
when I was 14 seven years ago I loved
Ben Shapiro Stephen Crowder and Candace
Owens I'm telling you yo you were 14
that's so scary dude I can't even say
that when I was younger and I was kind
of like growing up I I loved seeing it
when Ben Shapiro like owned people I
thought it was so cool
the Gateway huh absolutely I've talked
about this a lot on my platforms but I
really do attribute kind of you
um going kind of the opposite way and
I'm not not saying this just because I'm
here I actually like attribute a lot of
uh kind of you pulling me out of that
Meme hole
because when I was younger I feel like
if I if I wasn't let like kind of teach
something else or like um something like
that I would I could have might as well
just fall into the meme home possibly
wow that's really nice to hear yeah
because I mean the reason that I like
doing leftovers is because I think it is
important
uh and it's nice to know that it it
works you know and some in some small
ways some a lot of people are saying
same here
it explains a lot if their fans are 14
year olds and don't get me wrong there's
plenty of dumb asses I'm sure of all
ages that watch them but I I do think
that uh yeah like love said I think you
really identified it love the the Epic
Ownage content is uh you know owning
people with facts and logic is um very
appealing to uh to
young people I was going to say young
men I guess just young people in general
but it does seem like Their audience is
it's a young 99 man yeah Jake says I'm
18. I've been watching Ethan basically
my whole life and like some of eth and
like some of Ethan's social justice
Warrior vids I got recommended a ton of
crowder
Rogan Shapiro and became a mug clubber
leftovers brought me back whoa right
because the um the the it was and you've
reflected and talked about this at
length but it is a very thin line
between the making fun of embarrassing
sjw content that you used to make which
wasn't necessarily explicitly right wing
and I mean I know you weren't right wing
so that wasn't even like an undercurrent
but it's only one
step over the line to
the same content that Crowder and
Shapiro and all those people are making
about those same people which is much
more explicitly political and you know
right laning so I've talked at length
about it but that's why
I felt the need to do this switch and it
happened when I would put out a video
and I would see like people retweeting
it like Ben Shapiro and Stephen Crowder
and that gorilla mind who's that psycho
uh gorilla mine uh uh cernovich yeah and
I would see them retweeting I'd be like
dude right wait wait I really Disturbed
me yeah it's a wake-up call for sure and
so
I did have to go through this
metamorphosis publicly anyway yeah
and I get it I mean like you know those
videos were funny a lot of you know
people are cringe and you were pointing
out the cringe and you weren't wrong but
yeah it really is
just one step over further to the right
and you wind up down that hole algorithm
hole which yeah is evidenced by
like we see people saying in the chat
there's a lot of yet Latin person says I
was super conservative at age 13 to 16
then I pivoted to Young Turks and
started to move center now at 23.
why are all these young kids caring
about politics I didn't give a [__]
about that [__] when I was young I don't
even think it's politics I think it's
just literally owned wow that was funny
yeah and back then it wasn't even like
transcend transgender issues or anything
like that it was just like more more
like maybe a financial issues feminism
you know 2014 2015 it was all like these
crazy feminists which that's still out
there too but it's definitely become way
more focused on like the gender issue
stuff well that's awesome and I uh
I'm actually really happy to hear that I
think that validates
what we're doing here in a way because
you know the more young people we can
activate and get involved and to see
through all this crazy
now becoming like violent
uh it's just counterproductive
destructive
tendencies that we see from
conservatives
um is awesome it's just awesome I mean
that's great but to go back to the issue
of Chris
so I was surprised by this just because
I had no idea I mean I didn't I mean and
who does right
because he he's married
he has a son he's still married and has
a son
[Music]
but but he's uh announced that he's
doing hormone replacement therapy
and he started kind of um
I don't know how to describe it because
he's not come out as like trans but
gender non-conforming I guess or
non-binary right non-binary
so he's
so people are freaking out you know and
I miss Mr Beast says everybody's a fan
of Mr B so he's going to have a lot of
conservatives yeah that's gonna break a
lot of their minds because
Mr Beast uh you know I think very
consciously has tried to remain Above
The Fray when it comes to anything
controversial and everything and um but
I was glad to see he was he was tweeting
out his support he's not you know he's
not being wishy-washy about it at all so
I gotta say these guys I'm so proud of
them one for Chris like people go what's
wrong with him like his brain's rotting
he's crazy he's got a wife and a kid and
how and it's just crazy and weird and
I'm like
this is a dude who
is in his mid-20s is married with a kid
has the best job in the world and makes
a [__] ton of money
and has everything to lose by going by
doing this right he has he has
everything to lose
the only Pro in this would be to
uh feel more himself his own well-being
his own well-being which is what he said
he said he thinks it saved his life
so these people they want they would
rather him be dead apparently yep or
miserable or miserable closeted right
yeah that's that's the American way
they're like yo come on hey what's up
dude yeah they would have much rather
Chris had stayed in his in their
traditional life and not
change any like literally
they I lost what I was gonna say
they want it all to be like bottled up
they want him to be the dad from
American Beauty yeah they would rather
suffer silently with everything that
they think is right then
then be himself beat themselves uh
what's interesting and it yeah it took
an incredible bravery and you know
if you find it weird that's because
you're just not used to seeing this kind
of stuff
uh because it's in the process of being
normalized
he didn't do anything wrong that's where
you guys are [__] crazy you're acting
like he did something wrong he's just
being true to himself you wanna
you know and it
this is a this is a guy
who
again yeah he's being true to himself
for the sake of himself and his kid and
his wife and his family they're still
all together
and uh that's correct I think it's
inspiring I think there's if there's
people
who are struggling themselves and seeing
this and seeing him talk about how he
turned around
um hopefully and I'm sure it will
because the audience is so massive
will inspire people to take care of
themselves as well but there's a really
ugly part of this too of course
bro what the [__] happened 130 000 likes
the top comment Mr Beast done showed him
the Beast
eggplant emoji
um Ollie London of course you guys this
this is the craziest thing
Ali London
is the absolute
he's like I don't even know how to
describe this guy
he went trans Korean and became he's the
first trans-racial guy and he wanted to
look like
you don't even know if it's the first uh
I mean maybe and now he has as many have
figured out that it's very very
lucrative
to ride the conservative hate train
Ali London has now joined their ranks
it's heartbreaking to see so many young
people feel compelled to change
themselves in their gender this is a
grown ass man dumb dumb idiot loser
he goes it's Harper has seen so many
young people this is a grown ass man
with a family
and also you've tried to turn yourself
Korean like you're the last person
that should be commenting on this wasn't
he convenience at some point or was it I
believe so but now now they're a big uh
D transition celebrity they they they
realize that's the
that's where the cloud is I've been
there I know
right
uh it's changed since gender learning to
accept our natural selves is extremely
difficult but loving ourselves is more
important are you [__] me in the
[__] right now you're gonna talk to
me about the the value of learning to
love yourself like let's say that's true
you've been through quite a journey
Ollie would you deprive other people of
that Journey like I'm glad that you came
out on top you went trans you went you
went transracial you went Korean and now
you've you've settled on yourself and
you're happy so you want to deprive
other people of that Journey you want to
judge them you want to hate them because
now you're fine and people are paying
you you hateful [__] trollish
God I hate him so such a cynical [__]
dude yeah
just suck my tongue dude
he wrote a book called gender Madness
that's what I'm saying it's so lucrative
to hop on this train man it's just pays
so well that's that's what's going on
here
it is interesting to think the crowd is
just entertaining a bunch of 14 year
olds like if he had a live show and it's
just like kids she's like kids
oh that's good
um
so let's see then Chris responded to it
let's take a look
he responded HRT and it's only been two
months so
again being proud proudly himself
uh in case you missed it this is his alt
he said
uh informed consent HRT saved my and
many others lives the hurdles GNC people
what's GNC gender non-conformity okay
people have to jump through to get
life-saving gender affirming Health Care
is a in a first world country as wild to
me just let people make informed
decisions about their own bodies no
there it is
uh no that's kind of their whole shtick
dude
Carl being a supportive King even Mr
Beast and this one I really was like
okay Beast is cool man
he's coming out here supporting his
homie and he is sticking his neck out
because you know this is such a yeah
there's no more yeah there's no
way to
avoid the backlash they're gonna boycott
Mr Beast now good luck
yeah you'll be about as sex was
boycotting Bud Light yeah we're
boycotting air Brothers these trans
people been breathing the same air as us
I'll be holding my breath
got me an oxygen [__] tank from China
got me an oxygen shake from Russia there
ain't no gay people in Russia and said
um
Mr Beast has been very supportive I love
that for him I really do love that for
him that's so cool of him
uh here's more
this dude said uh bro what the [__]
happened he came out and said here to
help with the ratio we love the
this guy said in a few years looking
back at this thread and remember they
were never your friends only Yes Men
cowards hope you come out of this safe
like dude what are you talking about
so cynical
Mr B's opinion irrelevant ratio love
that for you a few years look back at
this thread remember they were never
your friends
he's saying in a couple years when you
realize the terrible mistake you've made
as we know there's a huge number of
people uh trans people that regret it
about less than three percent
uh you'll realize that they were never
your friends because they didn't make
you want to kill yourself like I would
have
right it was just
having a hard time with the the logic
there
I was supportive of course uh I wanted
to voice my support for him oh what a
and and uh
the commenters were gracious enough to
call me uh transphobic for misgendering
him or something oh and then of course
uh uh the man who cares the most uh
keemstar had this to say trans right
Defender keemstar Ethan Klein is being
called out for labeling Chris a king
after Chris announced they are on home
run hormone replacement therapy many
feel Ethan should have used Queen
instead
I support you King his of his uh
supporting evidence is this comment with
no likes
zero likes zero engagement nice
nice what do you think you are
supporting if you're calling her a king
people are so annoying and dumb and like
just shut up do you think you like doing
narrow DiCaprio yeah he was there he was
in the chat
so shout out to them
now there's this whole other story
this guy is claiming that Chris reached
out and threatened to sue him because of
a tweet he made
look at this Chris old Chris would make
fun of new Chris this people always say
that about me
the whole do you think would be making
fun of new Ethan it's like
so [__] dumb it's like I'm me ask me
here let me tell you I'm me no I
wouldn't
it's me I think I'm the authority on
what I'm what me would do me why did you
unmatch me also this insinuation Chris
would have definitely made fun of this
trans person look at this trans idiot
old Chris would have said like no
because that's that was the big focus of
Mr Beast videos a few years ago was just
dunking on people that's always been
their content it's also just so funny
like that Chris probably was struggling
and was thinking about this and the
Chris on the right is the Chris that I
imagine the Chris on the left would be
proud of and like happy before that's
what I think and people say oh olithu
would make fun of new Ethan I'm like I'm
so much happier and better off now and
every perceivable way yeah I I think I
would be I would be super happy and well
you can just ask me because I'm me
[Music]
and I'll tell you that's true I wouldn't
make fun of that I'm cool
old me made the decisions to become new
mirror
in fact I'm just me
uh so this guy's saying that Chris is
threatening to sue him now from what I
can tell this is not real
but what he's doing actually is super
[__] up and maybe Chris should sue him
for the joke
because he's put he put out this message
uh
yo whoever I saw the street from you
today and wanted to say my lawyers will
be in contact with you shortly with a
court notice for misspelled defamation
this idiot wrote himself don't know why
you or anyone would tweet something so
hatred
towards anyone on the internet so
blatantly disgusting see you soon
[__] yeah obviously that's not
[__] real and then he responded what
the [__] the thing is that uh dumbasses
will think it's real a lot of people
think it's real Sports and I started to
even get a little confused because
that's a wild thing to just put out
there
that's actually
that might be defamation but so I think
this is Chris that would be real irony
if it does too for defamation but for
making up the lie about suing for
defamation Chris love says that account
got banned okay not surprised yeah Elon
Musk Twitter shame on you
yeah that's tough
um I'm assuming this was this was Chris
saying that
this never happened he says my lawyer
will be in contact with you Mr Beast
but this guy's still running with it
that it's uh real I saw a tick tock of
someone claiming that Chris reached out
to them too and this was when I got
confused I was like this [__] is not
real right and this and the comments
here this has a million this is where
it's really [__] up a million likes
1.1 million likes
all the comments are like Chris like
transphobic and hating and believing it
14 million views on this video
so here's what it's posting
it's posting this message that we just
read on Twitter
now he's posting a fake summons
like this guy needs this is now we're in
lawsuit territory he he posted a fake
summons
I mean that's so over the top
that you have to assume it's all fake
right
I can't imagine it's real there's no
shot yeah I mean I don't believe it but
I I mean
but this guy actually needs to be sued
now because this is [__] insane 13
million views and if you go to the
comments let's go this is the guy who
was tweeting about it he's banned
Chris please take action against him it
would be so epic and poetic
well you'd have to
you have to prove damages somehow right
like well so indefinite
isn't it it has to know like malice and
and provably provable damages aren't
those like kind of the
I think two Thin view punitive damages
which are limited but
I'm not really sure
there's also certain crimes that have
like implied damage if they're accused
of doing something heinous enough
uh
dude they wrote his name on the lawsuit
Alex fear Buck Francis no they're not
writing your Twitter handle in the
lawsuit
um
stupid ass
and then it's signed Chris
with his Twitter handle
dude I didn't even look okay yeah
obviously that's fake so but I saw this
and I'm truly disturbed by this if you
go to the comments again 13 million
views insane he's we've got a uh
Christian he is risen Chris has fully
lost it for real Chris is a living L now
your honor to hurt my feelings so this
is not real
these all three thousand likes these
people all think this is real nah I'm
with beerbach Chris hella insecure for
this
Chris L he can't be sued for defamation
for posting two pictures of Chris
publicly posing you can't be super
definition for lying about this old
thing
Chris Chris is going straight down just
like the re just like his test
fear Buck you're sentenced to five
minutes in timeout for hurting his
feelings so this is all
people thinking this is real while just
stunning
and this is part of what's so [__] up
about transphobia
now it's like this guy made this really
Brave decision to come out against with
nothing to gain everything to lose
and now they're gonna [__] straight
up lie on him to assassinate his
character as well
this is so wrong great [__] up if I
you know ugh
I recognize that account the guy's
always been scum and prominent Aiden
Ross sympathizer and Dick Rider says uh
Mega awesome
well that certainly doesn't surprise me
is he an influencer or oh wait I see I
got confused by the verified he just
paid for it like an idiot
yep
dummy
you want to talk about embarrassing you
paid for Twitter blue
hey check out this guy he's wearing
makeup
let's [__] them up
hey check them out this guy's got log
hair let's get him
you're like a bunch of rednecks in a
pickup truck
crazy
so uh I hope that guy gets sued I really
do I really do
um here's a bunch of I don't know if I
need oh sneako's involved I'm sure he
had some Ollie London you scum
went from masculine Family Man based on
what is he masculine you don't know
anything about him because he looks like
a guy
with a two-year-old son to transgender
with because he goes with a transgender
dude with a family
and a son
pumped full of estrogen hormones all in
the space of a few months Chris from
YouTube's biggest
uh
Channel Mr Beast decided we can
transitioning two months ago and Ollie
London who has been totally irrelevant
he's totally irrelevant totally nobody
takes him seriously but the minute he
comes out with this grift now people are
listening seventeen thousand likes like
don't you see how easy this grift is
he's probably making more money than he
ever has
it's so transparent
I don't know man these people seem evil
like to go from
being trans yourself
to being anti-trans for a paycheck
Nico's take oh brother this is gonna be
good
God
what the [__] happened the people that
are encouraging that's that's a sneako
when he sees his wife get a [__]
bucket load of bukaki on her face
what the [__] happened the people that
are encouraging us that's snico as his
wife grabs the other dudes
[__] and tells her how bad she wants it
she watches
they're not they think that they're
doing the right thing they're all
brainwashed even Mr Beast thinks that
he's doing the right thing by supporting
his friend Chris brainwashed if you
really cared you would not encourage his
delusion now you would look at the long
term if you really cared you would let
him kill himself
and see that this is something that he's
doing because he is brainwashed by
social media because he's living in the
west where this is pushed by a bunch of
garbage if you were really his friend
right now you would hear what I'm saying
because this is so gross I didn't even
listen to it
you don't know anything about anything
dude
uh here's a sneaker tweet
we are praying for you Chris if you
realize how much impact your decisions
are having in the youth that's actually
a I agree I think he's having he's
actually
probably saving a lot of young kids
who are scared
oh yeah yeah
it's sad I feel for the I feel for the
trans people it's just
the world is so unfair and so mean it's
just so mean right now
hateful even violent
I don't like it
but anyway shout out to Chris
uh for making this very brave decision
to be true to himself with nothing to
gain I think that's worth this man had
everything to lose by doing this you all
think he did this for fun or something
and uh Mr Beast for supporting his buddy
that's awesome
good for both of them
love them
all right let's talk about something
funny now
uh let's talk about the Ohio bus driver
this is a really cool story I there's
some conflict
uh but I think interestingly a lot of
people support the bus driver who's
calling little kids little shits and
pieces of [__] and Jackie Miller a 68
year old bus driver from Ohio resigned
so she fired her she resigned
a resign means quit
I suppose I heard she was fired
she resigned from her job as a bus
driver after a two-minute video of her
yelling at her junior high school bus
riders went viral
apparently the kids on the bus were
spraying a perfume she's allergic to
she blames it for causing an asthma
attack just one month before
two kids are so crazy so crazy they're
like yo did you hear Jack uh Mrs Miller
she had an asthma attack let's bring the
perfume on and see if we can get her to
have another one
Washington Post reports she stepped down
and now people well let's watch the
video so they're trying to kill her
essentially
awesome kids are crazy of course some
little shit's gonna have a cell phone
and put it on Tick Tock you know like
it's just the kids are [__] nuts is
it a dash cam or I think it oh no
there's someone's filming it with their
phone I'm a fan of her
so let's see
you know when I saw this without the
context I was like okay this is pretty
wild
but they were trying to kill her these
are all Ben Shapiro and Crowder fans by
the way who are trying to kill their bus
driver with perfume I don't know about
that but these are the people
can't do anything
I can smell it she's like a Miss
Crabtree from South Park the bus driver
you know oh yeah wow there's an
interesting uh parallel yeah at least
she didn't like punch anyone in the face
I've seen that on the bus that's pretty
wild she used her words
yeah I'm done
I'm done yes stop kicking some [__]
serious ass let's go do you hear me yes
my foot's gonna be so far up your
goddamn ass into a dangle let your
goddamn nose I'm done with you
set phone in your bag now you give it to
me all right fine but you can't have
your phone on the bus
some instances know you kind of use your
phone on the bus what are you supposed
to do when I was younger we were not
able to have any uh Middle School it had
to be in the bag yeah well cell phones
didn't exist obviously when I was taking
this bus you know what we did when we
didn't have something to distract us we
would like tear the cushions apart
you want us to try to kill the bus
driver right
done
any kid who says I didn't do anything in
that tone
freaking smell it one thousand percent
did the thing should have made their
asses walk home I'm taking an Uber [__]
you guys get the [__] out
you like to start [__] too Maya you're
no innocent you're no innocent Angel
here but she has an idea up to here man
these kids have put her through [__] you
don't even know about
done with this [__]
done
I've had my fill I'm done no she's doing
her she's doing her straight resignation
[__] you all to a Bus full of kids
she's having like her moment you know
that you fantasize up [__] all you
little pieces of [__]
that's pretty epic telling a bunch of
kids to [__] off
walk off this goddamn bus right now let
you people walk the [__] she's so angry
she's like Chris Farley's character and
um uh [__] Billy Madison he's like
I'll turn this goddamn bus around I love
the obscenities she's just awesome
she's bright red how much more do you
think anybody can freaking take
shut your mouth I don't wanna because
someone just coughed
[Laughter]
it sounds like someone just coughed me
shut your mouth I don't want to hear
another goddamn word out of your mouth
oh
excuse me
excuse what did I just [__] tell you
dude whoa
hero our villain uh
hero
this girl [__] man what if you find out
that she has like a violent history and
she's that's we don't have all the
context but I mean the context that I
have is like you were just describing
Ethan when I was in Middle School I I
have memories [__] out of teachers oh
yeah I definitely deserve to be chewed
out like that so you know kids are like
genuine size so Psychopaths like
Psychopaths is when like you don't grow
up
yesterday I was telling cam when I was
in Middle School my Middle School music
teacher uh he he was first year he was
brand new teacher
and we used to [__] torment this guy
like
so badly it was it was in band class and
we would constantly just like blow our
instrument really loud while he was
talking and then he would get mad and
start yelling at that person and as he's
yelling at one person somebody over here
behind him would do it again and we'd do
this for like 20 minutes
the problem is that is so [__] upset
it is pretty funny I mean it's funny but
like that's why I'm saying like he had
every right to [__] scream at us like
that he would have absolutely been in
the right to do that she ate those kids
up
oh
I think every teacher is probably
fantasized about it yeah they've all had
that moment for sure
you think it's funny
you think it's funny hero no you didn't
you're so full of [__] Jackson
I like how she knows all their names too
my Buster driver didn't know all of our
name they just came they dropped us off
I wasn't that personal see at one point
she learned all their names yeah that's
sweet that's the time to [__] off she
put in her Manifesto
they're on a list Maya Jackson
done
done yo there's some major sound bite
Potentials in here Zach yeah I'll come
through
not damn word on any of you
Ohio Jackie
I think she's taking him home
[Music]
damn I'd be scared she gotta drive that
[__] off a cliff to be honest all right
yeah like actually I will walk home
there it is oh wow good stuff good stuff
so let's do a poll I know it seems that
everybody loves her but let's just let's
uh
solidify it all right what's the poll uh
uh was she right was the bus driver or
was she wrong
was the bus driver right or wrong
that's it
that's it that's the pulse driver option
one right or wrong was she right
or was she wrong all right I'm throwing
up the poll for freaking out like that
I have a feeling it's going to be lots
of support for our drive angry or our
wonderful driver here should we reach
out and hire her
oh my god
dude you're gonna turn on me wash that'd
be a great call maybe you like [__] you
you're full of [__]
you're [__] phone away or maybe she
can do you can come and yell at us like
individually yo do you think she'd call
in and start yelling I'll reach out
reach out she would make me cry that'll
be a paid gig yeah I want her we need
her part of this Ohio Jackie
Tatum says uh when I was in eighth grade
I stole my fat teachers Brownie and
shared it with my friends
and we came back from lunch there was a
crime scene tape in her classroom with
wanted signs pasted all over the hallway
really no there wasn't you got yeah he
uh he got told on he said you went you
went to jail
so what do we got here
it's pretty overwhelmingly uh right
there are there are some wrongs though
there are some I would like
I mean I I don't I think it's very
[__] funny but I mean it's not the
appropriate reaction yeah I'm with you
dude
it's funny I agree I would have probably
laughed in her face when I was younger
too I would have enjoyed that [__] being
there too but it's not right it's not
right and like there's probably plenty
of innocent kids that had to suffer for
it too and like I'd be scared if I was
just sitting there I'd be genuinely sure
for my life I imagine she gave them many
warnings that I need more history I need
more stories yeah my brain caught me
last week
Fox News had her on last week oh come on
why do they have to take everything I
just saw we like to support our bus
drivers we hate children just like her
our position is [__] kids
your thoughts here pull it up I want to
watch it
she's they're gonna make it about
wokeness right they're good they're
gonna talk okay these woke kids think
that they can do whatever they want for
sure
for sure
dude was there any trans people on the
bus that uh were instigating this any
antifa person we somehow make this about
trans people
so let's see uh
she resigned oh here people made a
GoFundMe for her because I guess so many
people were feeling it's got a hundred
and ten thousand dollars a vacation and
retirement fund oh there you go
probably
she does deserve a break clearly she
needs it
she's stuck man she's like I gotta yell
at more kids it was a brutal one Maria
said we made our Music Teacher quick
because we threw a water balloon at his
desk ruining a bunch of important
documents he quit right there
you know it seems like a good idea but
it's in those moments you realize you're
like I'm the bad guy you're like I went
to I think that that is yeah I mean I've
gone too far too old-timey but I feel
like
I feel like uh it's not your fault
getting yelled getting chewed out like
that is probably a good thing in the
long run because that's part of growing
up is realizing that you can't really be
a little [__] and there are consequences
to your actions and you know
I would love to hear a bunch of these
stories though we should have a call an
episode where everyone just talks about
the most [__] up thing they did to a
teacher yeah I'm seeing a lot in the
chat uh that could be a really fun
segment actually uh Skyler says I've
seen teachers get absolutely bullied
into tears yeah that's that's sad yeah
that sucks
one time a kid put a thumbtack on a
cushion I mean that's like a cartoon
thing
so uh Miller has since apologized for
her action
and she made it clear she wouldn't
change much about how she acted
I'm sorry the way this went down I truly
am I do not I do apologize for my action
on that day but I won't take it back
that's my girl this is a plight of all
bus drivers we are treated in the worst
possible sense of the word stand up my
brothers bus drivers unite they need a
union for real though probably get
minimum wage for that there's just no
words to say how grateful I am for
people supporting me
uh the superintendent said this Behavior
exhibited by the bus driver is
unacceptable and will not be tolerated
there it is
I think we talked about everything
wow
but for the most part how long we've
been going we've been going for two
hours and 45 minutes wow some reason
well I have the Ariana Grande thing
Nick Cannon wants to have a 13th baby
with Taylor Swift YouTuber gets shot
filming a prank
funny awesome love it
see that right there
what you just said the YouTuber got shot
for doing a prank that's what happens if
you don't have a bus driver yell at you
when you're 13. fair enough that's where
you wind up
and you never learned your lesson you
keep escalating until you get shot for
[__] with the wrong person it's true
all right well if we're gonna go for a
bit longer I need to pee so I'll be
right back okay
aren't you never mind I miss a B I miss
a b oh look at that feels empty in here
sucks Lena's gone too I miss Lena Miss
Lena look at that beautiful purple
beautiful purple cell
that's Lena I guess the camera that is
not not here nowhere that's Lena
[Music]
uh one of my class somebody Jim said uh
one of my classmates poisoned my teacher
with Mark uh marker board cleaning oh my
gosh
it's that Expo [__] like the uh
wow I hope she's all right uh
real quick I just want to say one month
out till Zach Lewis live with the Roxy
where exactly one month away any tickets
left there how many tickets left come on
say how many there are a few days so get
yours today make sure there's a few
tickets they're going fast folks limited
Supply get what get it while you we are
this close to being sold out I'm gonna
say that
now is your chance now we're never
people because it's the last La it's the
last La show
uh here's another one I'm a middle
school computer science teacher in New
Hampshire and my school is consistently
having knife fights and kids getting
high that's awesome kids getting high is
that's standard but knife fights Jesus
only so much you can do at school when
the parents do nothing
I mean it's New Hampshire baby Live Free
or Die Live Free or Die that's right
yeah what can I say
uh are we gonna have a 420 special this
year so we were talking about it um just
the other day actually that we might try
and do something 420 lands on
a Thursday which is normally leftovers
day and you know I gotta tell you I had
like I had this instinctual thoughts
like oh perfect 420 we can do like a
uh you know a pro-legalization kind of
like segment around that
and I remember it's like we kind of
live in that world already I mean at
least it feel I guess it just feels that
way here in California it's completely
[__] legal that's boring let's get
high
but um yeah we might instead just do it
on the Friday after
um uh Eva wasn't here any of the times
that we did those guess whose highs
before so maybe doing it with ELO would
add like an interesting uh
New Angle to it I think that would be
like getting grilled instead of just
being grilled by Dad it's getting
grilled by Mom and Dad yeah you know
those uh moments before you'd go into
your house in high school and you were
like and you prepared yourself for a
conversation
oh yeah where the uh spray the smelly
stuff to cover up the smell don't be
drunk don't be drunk
yeah everybody's saying uh must be nice
yeah I mean it's it's spread quite a bit
I know but I suppose there are still
quite a few states where it's extremely
illegal which is just so wild to think
about they'll cut your balls off they
can't catch you with a little dime bag
yeah oh castrate You for Smoking Weed
something that comes from the earth come
on
come on Joe could [__] stroke of a
pen
and when I get hot by the pool wasn't
that just like Justin Trudeau's first
thing is he made weed federally legal in
his like first three months or something
I don't know I don't know enough about
Canadian politics I know it's been
mostly legal there for a while now some
Canadian will say in chat I'm sure yeah
I'm a Canadian friends are talking about
Joe Biden I saw a picture of him where
he says he's running again huh yep I'm
trying to find it the picture was so
weird and funny I have to talk oh the
one where he's got like the crooked
smile
with this going on
dude he's literally like
at first I didn't think about it I was
like wait
this man is either having or recently
had a stroke
his face is the left side of his face is
drooped yeah
a very strange photo I'm looking for it
right now maybe it was POTUS
Purge nobody
it was so weird [__] out
why am I not seeing it I'm still looking
all right well anyway
um stop laughing it's not funny
it is funny
uh I'm not like super
I'm not very familiar with Ariana
I know Ian is a Stan Olivia you stand
her there's some stands I know lots
about Missouri
Ian you're a stand don't hide it yeah
I'm I'm a fan we talk about Ari
sometimes from time to time
so good you guys know can help me then
recently fans have become concerned
about her
uh thinness is that what it is yes she's
filming the wicked movie in London right
now
would you like the musical yes of course
she's in England which has like the most
disgusting paparazzi
uh
pieces of [__] ever
so they're posting side by sides and
I don't know
um
Ariana attended an event held by Jeff
Goldblum
last week fan showed a lot of concern in
the comments
Wicked star Ariana Grande
Cynthia whatever and Jeff goldbluman
a new photo shoot I don't know this
well without doing what uh
yeah the comments are all pretty
commenting so what do we I I kind of
want to just have like a larger uh
conversation before I show her tick tock
are people out of line for expressing
concern I don't I mean she's like super
[__] famous
um I think that anyone probably talking
about your bodies too much and the world
talking about it is also too much yeah
that's kind of the thing is it's like
let's say it's true and she has
developed some sort of eating disorder
or something does everybody uh
constantly commenting in under every
photo about her commenting on her weight
of course not yeah so but at the same
time
it's like I think but like at the same
time like in a sense
I get the people too yeah discourse can
happen like gossip discourse these are
just the the peanut gallery she's like
this famous God to everybody else and if
they and especially as fans if they care
about her they're like yo what's going
on she's trusting concern how can they
not right but when a conversation is
opened it also opens the floodgates for
all the trolls and like disgusting
things and those overflow and overwhelm
the actual points I'm not saying that
the net is not bad for her I'm sure it
is if there's anything going on with
your body
people are gonna dog you for it and it
will always be bad but there's this
dialogue happening where it's like
people need to not comment on anyone's
body and I just wonder like I know that
it's going to make her feel bad if she
has I don't know what's going on with
her she said in this video she's healthy
okay
uh but if she let's just say
hypothetically if she did have an eating
disorder or some kind of condition or
something like
people are gonna talk about it
I mean obviously you want people to be
mean and not mean and more compassionate
about it
but I don't know I'm just kind of like
I think her I think her point is well
made though I mean here's her here's her
video she put out a tick tock
she looked totally she looks healthy to
me so I don't know I mean some of those
pictures she looked
pretty thin but it could be a weird
angle or something I I don't know
on my way to work soon I just wanted to
end I don't do this often I don't
like it I'm not good at it I don't like
I'm not good at it and I don't like it
but I just wanted to address your
concerns about my body and talk a little
bit about
what it means to be a person
with a body and to be seen and to be
paid such close attention to I think we
could be I think we should be gentler
and less comfortable commenting on
people's bodies no matter what if you
think you're saying something good or
well-intentioned whatever it is healthy
unhealthy big small this that sexy not
sexy I I don't we just shouldn't we
should really work towards not doing
that as much
there are well I get where she's coming
from right we could all be nicer
foreign
if you have someone close to you
who's like looking like deathly ill
you're not just gonna if you ignore it
not say anything that's almost
yeah if somebody has best to you yeah no
matter how hard you stand Ariana Grande
she is not close to you well it seems
like you don't know making a more
General point about because look she's a
she's a she's one of the most famous
people in the world so obviously nothing
she says is going to change how people
are going to talk about her on the
internet I think she's making a general
point
which I I get it right she's trying to
but but I just I don't know I don't know
she basically says at the end she isn't
super specific about it but she says
like if you're speaking about someone's
body and you think that something's
wrong like they're most likely already
working on it they most likely have a
support system so I was wondering if
maybe yeah she was trying to tell people
like calm down I've got it right
well let me let me uh ways to come I
know that oh God okay I'm not gonna read
chat while I do this because y'all are
annoying as [__]
no matter what if you think you're
saying something good or
well-intentioned whatever it is healthy
unhealthy big small this that sexy not
sexy I I don't we just shouldn't we
should really work towards not doing
that as much
there are ways to compliment someone or
to ignore something that you see that
you don't like
um that I think we should help each
other work towards just to aim towards
being safer and keeping each other safer
but I just also wanted to say
one
there are many different kinds of
beautiful there are many different ways
to look healthy and beautiful
I know personally for me the body that
you've been comparing my current body to
was the unhealthiest version of my body
I was
on a lot of antidepressants and drinking
on them and eating poorly and at the
lowest point of my life when I looked
the way you consider my healthy but that
in fact wasn't my healthy
um and I shouldn't I know I shouldn't
have to explain that but I do feel like
maybe having an openness and some sort
of vulnerability here will be something
like good my government I don't know I
don't know but that's the first thing
healthy can look different
the second thing is you never know what
someone is going through so even if you
are coming from a loving place in a
Caring Place that person probably is
working I mean this advice is only
applicable to people in the real life I
mean when you're talking about a public
figure none of this matters there's
going to be a gajillion comets saying
every single thing you can imagine no
matter what
so right
right but I mean I imagine that the
amount of comments have at least
somewhat decreased since this video
maybe her fans are less like yeah
I mean it's fair to say like hey guys I
know you guys are concerned like I saw
once um
what's his name the dude who lost a ton
of weight it was super bad
Jonah Hill I saw Jonah Hill once put out
a video on Instagram that I thought was
interesting of kind of the same he's
like listen I know you all like are
trying to be supportive but please just
don't stop just stop mentioning my way
that that actually made sense to me when
he's like fans
you don't need it I don't know maybe you
could pull it up because that I remember
seeing that one and thinking
uh yeah
or has a support system that they are
working on it with and
you never know so be gentle with each
other
and with yourselves and thirdly
um
the third one's unrelated I guess I just
wanted to
send some love your way and tell you
that you're beautiful no matter what can
I uh
what does that mean
when she says you are beautiful
everyone is beautiful what does that
mean like there is no right way to look
there's no right way to be beautiful
okay what do you what do you think about
that
you think beauty is objective Ethan
like what I I don't understand what
you're confused by
trying to think how to put this well
it's not nose not
but
I'm like you don't know me I'm [__]
busted
you know what I mean
I'm busted
I just don't know what it means when
somebody he's like you haven't met them
it might be pieces of [__]
our PR is is uh Charles Manson beautiful
I was probably not speaking to
Charlotte's Maps Okay well she said
everyone
[__] like checkmate
everyone but Charles Manson
I mean I feel like it's like a
reassurance thing to uh you know people
may be dealing with body dysmorphia
Eating Disorders that's good that makes
sense to me yeah you're beautiful you're
okay yeah except except you
everyone except you Charles
you're dead but when you were alive you
were hideous everyone hated you
um
by the way I'm not wearing eyelashes or
eyeliner right now this is my face these
are my she looks amazing by the way
she's beautiful
she is yeah
so don't freak out about that now too
please oh my God but yeah
sending you guys a lot of love
and I think you're beautiful no matter
what you're going through no matter what
weight no matter what how you like to do
your makeup these days no matter what
cosmetic procedures you've had or not or
anything
um yeah I just think
you're beautiful and everyone but you
James Charles
you be everyone be yourselves James you
be someone else I beautiful
I stand by there
okay there it is sorry beautiful sorry
beautiful there she says uh but I I
guess I I see it when she's like please
just stop talking about my weight that
that makes sense sure yeah it reminded
me it was a little bit similar to a few
weeks ago when Selena Gomez was pretty
much forced by all of her comments to
talk about how her lupus medicine makes
her gain weight oh and everyone was like
why does she even have to talk about
this like everybody was commenting
disgusting things and it was it was
pretty much it was a similar
situation here's what Jonah Hill wrote
he said I know you mean well but I
kindly ask that you not comment on my
body he'll wrote with a heart emoji good
or bad I want to politely let you know
it's not helpful and doesn't feel good
much respect I I guess that resonated
with me the way he said it
thank you
you know what I mean
because I met some I I met some really
nasty people
you know hideous telling you
not everyone's beautiful
just you really take issue with that I
no not really I just I it's nothing
against her I just never know what that
means when people say it I mean it's not
that serious but I just I was always
like everybody
like everybody's beautiful I says really
everybody it feels disingenuous it feels
disingenuous
yeah you get what they're going for come
on
come on she's probably talking to like
the young girl on the other side yeah I
don't think she's thinking about Charles
Madison
[Music]
you are beautiful every single get away
except you James Charles
we need asterisks at least with a list
of people we don't like right exceptions
any of the Charles that's James Charles
Charles Manson right right someone said
you you resonated with you because he's
a man shut up the way I think the way he
wrote it in a way that resonates with me
okay I saw some uh discourse a few years
ago that she was too heavy
um back in like 2017 or something she'd
put on just like a little that's crazy
and now they're saying she's too skinny
so I think at this point she's kind of
like can you stop telling me like the
perfect way that you think I need to be
and just like back off and let me be how
I am I love that you're passionate about
this Ian yeah I'm stepping I switched to
myself love it wow yeah nice to hear
from you nice to see you she also said
something like you guys have been
talking about my body for a decade so
let me weigh in on it finally weigh in
oh but um I don't know if she used the
word way
all right let's all just forget about
everything let's just all forget about
everything everything is beautiful
nothing exists and everything is exists
is beautiful
everybody watching this you are
beautiful
except you Kevin you ugly [__]
shame on you Kevin
uh everybody is beautiful
God damn it
you [__] little pieces of [__]
I'm gonna drive this [__] bus right
off a cliff
your parents are gonna have to pick
teeth out of the bird corpse left
the only thing Lefty is gonna be that
Live Strong bracelet and your [__]
teeth you little [__]
I'm telling you
I've got gas cans in the back I'm gonna
light up on fire
hey bus driver [__] you
no [__] you [__] [__] well you're out
of this moving bus you [__] suck you
suck
all right I see how it is taking a
detour to the five about to you I hope
you guys enjoy swimming
learn to drive [__] oh yeah I'll
learn to drive
you never will because you're gonna die
in about five minutes
hey uh bus driver I'm about to 911 this
bust
you smell like eggs you look like you're
from the seconde's islands smell like
eggs the second yeah suck on these nuts
[__] oh now it's all now it's [__]
mass suicide hell no let's go I'm gonna
Waco this [__] buzz let's go
there's a bomb under every one of your
seats if I hear one more person scream
we're all [__] dead you understand me
[Music]
you ever been burned alive little Kevy
have you ever been broken have you ever
felt flesh
searing at your skin the the smell of
your friends burning cooking screaming
you smell like eggs
that's it everyone's dead
fart noises
tonight I'll go Cameron
it wasn't me no no I didn't do anything
I didn't do anything it literally wasn't
me Cameron
I pick you up in this bus I know where
you live
here's what I want you to think about
Cameron as you tell me I look like eggs
smell like eggs I look like I do look
more like an egg
I know where you live
yeah you've got that window outside your
bedroom you leave the you keep the
curtains up usually
can't really see outside it's dark but
you can see inside that's the crazy
thing you can see inside
but you can't see outside Cameron it
wasn't me no no no no
I'm just making a point lock your
windows tonight
lock your windows because you can't see
out that window you don't know if
somebody's there Cameron
I know where you live
I can't protect you at night
[Music]
okay and your little brother
he's a piece of [__] too
uh okay
and I'd love to discipline you both at
the same time with a knife
you're scaring me eggs bus driver should
be scared
no coughing
hey I didn't do anything I didn't do
anything and Jackie anything yeah so
anything anyway uh We've pretty much
said it all we've done it all
uh Ariana I hope you know it's it's I I
get it I get it let's leave her alone
let's all have a pact we love her you've
been through enough
no more comments there it is nice well
on one hand maybe this is the conflict
I'm having I watch that and then I feel
bad because I comment on people's bodies
all the time
but then I'm saying I'm like
I don't know because so so so is this a
calm damnation of me do I need to change
I don't know that I can stop talking
about people's bodies do you feel
beautiful Ethan
um
um like physically yeah no you don't
like how you look
not at this not at this exact moment no
well you are beautiful you look Beauty
you are beautiful but you see this like
what you want to [__] me what do you
mean I'm beautiful I'm hot well no
you're glowing beauty doesn't
necessarily have to mean you know
physically it's you know you're handsome
yeah you're a good guy but I'm okay
let's just take the [__] complex
[__] take it it's ingenuous to say
everybody's beautiful it just is it
feels phony
because you know there's some ugly
[__] out there
it's just a fact of life it's just
numbers game statistics
somebody for everybody though there's a
beast out there there's a beast out
there for everybody all right let's wrap
it I felt worthless I felt ugly we're
over three hours you know what I'm
saying does anybody got my back on this
I don't I don't I figure nobody
being a little silly you are a beautiful
person
oh no not the whole kids and the bus hey
[__] put your phones away shut up you
you [__] son go back to ripping up
the seats like [__] kids did when
they were my age
[Music]
I hit the red and Sharpie on the back of
the seats that's it
I have a beautiful soul so saying you're
beautiful does that have a beautiful
soul because she's talking physically
she says if you're skinny or big she
didn't say you have a beautiful soul
like oh you love dogs and you got your
mom a really thoughtful present on her
birthday she's talking about physically
beautiful right mm-hmm well those are
two separate conversations so she's
saying you are physically beautiful to
everybody sorry
beautiful I think that's what she's
saying yeah sure
okay
I know y'all don't believe that
I don't think she's saying that I think
it's just a nice thing to say
to make people feel good yeah and that's
nice it's like telling everybody you're
gonna feel good she doesn't know you she
doesn't even know what you look like she
never met you because you can just take
the damn car you already you already
said it it is is Beauty and physical
attractiveness something that's
objective that's the same to everyone
no you already said no
um
so you don't think that you think beauty
is objective yeah pull up pull up all
the people she's data are probably punks
I'm just saying I don't know everybody's
beautiful except I only date like
handsome [__] with big dicks
well it's like it's like you looking at
the camera doing the show and being like
all of you are beautiful and amazing you
literally say it all the time I don't so
you're saying you're all well you do
well you're also not being like they're
all scrutinized for your body right now
you know I think I do it facetiously
like where it's like y'all beautiful I
love you there's some ugly people
watching this when he says that people
just know he's lying just know that some
of you listen there's some ugly people
watching the show right now it's just a
statistical fact yeah let's talk about
it
fat ugly and stupid
yeah I think you are disgusting I'm
gonna kill you it's easy to say
everyone's beautiful but let's look at
her ex-boyfriends talk about everyone's
beautiful I don't see any uh
Eric Cartman looking
dudes in her dating history
just saying I don't know nothing about
her dating history well except for Pete
Davidson we were together
she did date uh she did Mac Miller Mac
Miller she dated
one of her dancers oh he's probably fit
as hell right he was yeah
Ricky she talks about him and thank you
next let's pull up Ricky Ricky
guys let me see him shirtless
how come she doesn't date any fat guys
that's what I'm saying we're the fat
representation don't you know you got a
[__] some few fat guys just for just for
equality
you owe it to us fat guys
you gotta [__] a fatty for me this is
you know take one for the team just
prove that everyone's beautiful uh
uh and you know exactly what I'm saying
look here's the deal don't look fat
I gotta see her this uh dance guy
look I'm 40. I'm tired I'm sweaty I'm
fat I'm overweight he nailed it all
right let's see her her oh this is this
is the best photo we got about I'm
looking for full body bro that's not a
shirt
he just walks around like this that's
like I think that's like a chicken wire
I don't think that's a shirt
wait he also has like the Pete Davidson
like sunken eyes
kind of thing you know yeah I see it
that Crone Chic Brown cheek
Chrome chic
it is I'm in love that like I don't know
like I feel like women some not all but
there's like women want you to look like
you're on the verge of death
in a sense nobody's backing me up today
I know exactly
hold on I'm grabbing dude you all know
exactly women be like that women who
like like super skinny guys I want my
man to look like he could die at any
second
from drug abuse or starvation
this is him yeah
he's ugly I mean he's yeah he's hideous
he's stunning
yeah who would want to have sex with him
gross tiny nipples
there we go we have Pro we've identified
an issue let's make him insecure now
come on give me a break all right that's
enough for now I'm just having fun I
hope nobody's offended I'm just having a
good time you are also beautiful
you are all physically gorgeous
are you talking to our audience yeah no
you earlier said that a bunch of ugly
[__] are watching this that was
just so now I'm serious yeah no
everybody is gorgeous I mean a good 20
of you
out there you're a bunch of [__]
I love that
no you're all so hot
everybody wants to [__] you guys
all the time
[Music]
nah but I mean to me it's more about
being a like good person right I think
when I think you can be attracted to
someone once you get to know their
personality and you're like oh this
person's awesome I love them and then
you become attracted I think that's
where attraction begins especially when
you're ugly you got to work with that
I'm not physically attracted to you guys
like that's what I had to work in my
life I was like no I'm a really good guy
once you get to know me you'll find me
attractive
and it works sometimes
not all the times
only needs to work once
that's it you just use these will work
once
if you're hot you probably are dumb and
annoying
if you're like a 10 out of 10 you're
dumb and annoying probably
you can't be so hot and also so funny
that's not fair yes that's not allowed
it's not cool you know what I have to
say I've met a lot of dudes in my life
who are both like super hot and funny
where where are those people
maybe it's just me but you have their
number yeah you want to give me some
names I can't recall anyone specifically
but I remember always thinking like this
is not fair
you're talking about me of course yeah
thank you
thank you so much
all right anyway I'm just kidding I hope
I didn't offend anyone we're just having
a good time here so uh well good news
all around
just a little old timey fun you guys
know what it is
hey it's a little old timey I got my eye
on you
what's a matter you got Crohn's disease
or you just
happy to see me or are you gay what are
you gay I got Crohn's disease are you
gay
uh yeah thank you guys we had a really
terrific viewership today I don't know
if people all of a sudden like the show
or if it's the topic oh it's a juicy
juicy drama going on but I'll tell you
this
subscribers for the month
993. [__]
thank you
[Music]
money
let's go
[Music]
foreign
we going to Disney World we're going
baby foreign
that Star Wars
pasta
oh one thing I forgot to mention
this shirt's coming out
of memory said next Thursday
this is another
of my Editions
so I came out a little bit but you get
the idea
Zuck is a soul-sucking demon
it was really hard to capture this one
it took me a while to put that one
together
the Jeff Bezos and the Elon Musk ones
really
wrote themselves I'm making Meats now
smoking these meats here smoking those
meat puppies the dogs are worried about
me all right guys
I do love you
you don't have to be
beautiful to be loved although it helps
let's be real
I mean look at me everyone hates me
because I'm fat
all right I'll stop it now I'm just all
right let's go stop it don't talk about
my boss I'm sorry I'm sorry you're right
so tomorrow we'll be back with leftovers
in the morning
loving that gonna have lots to talk
about and then on Friday we're gonna be
having a fantastic we're not doing that
no Mount Fuji
no suicide forest reenactment in
shame on you for even suggesting that
[Music]
uh
and Friday uh we have got a fun little
gag we're planning
we're going to
put sound counseling headphones on Zach
and make him do sound bites
the first time I'm hearing about this
yes sir
are you gonna do sound bites without
hearing
okay excited
I mean I don't I don't know how that's
gonna go but I guess we'll see you have
to just kind of we'll set you up with
the grid of all of the camera feeds so
you can see everything but you won't be
able to hear anything and you just need
to It's like a
like in Star Wars where Obi-Wan puts
like the feel the face mask yeah you
have to with the force but my ears my
ears are gonna be blindfolded yeah I'm
getting you like like the [__] they wear
on the tarmac at the airport drown out
like a jet engine got it uh that was a
suggestion from a fan actually we saw
that in the comments yeah good idea it's
gonna be fun so uh anyway we'll see you
on Friday and then Saturday who can
forget the big day that's the big day
we'll be here I'm very much looking
forward to it
but guys thank you so much I love you
all thank you for so much support
through the bbtv drama which I am so
happy to say is hopefully gonna be
behind us which is the last thing I
expected honestly but I'm very happy
about that holy smokes
dude we're gonna have the best trip
I'll be rocking my whole bbtv swag
[Music]
we should definitely do that merch bbtv
we gotta get head to toe
we're a Disney trip
you know
[Music]
um
do you work for bbtv no no
just big fans they they just paid me 620
000.
we got the music playing
all right I gotta go thank you guys see
you tomorrow morning
[Music]